I also still want to know, Connor, what do you think of Steven
within, you know, knowing this person for a couple weeks? What
do you think of him leaking all of his DMs with Lauren Southern,
including the name of Lauren Southern's kid that she's trying
to keep secret? >> Going to end your relationship, call
him a piece of backstab him, all that front. >> You've
stated your principles, Connor. You've stated. You stated you'd
have to distance yourself from anybody doxing. You stated that.
You did, Connor. >> Putting Cream and Chud Logic and Dusty
on the same level kicks ass. Chud Logic also DM'd an underage
girl, right? Who lied about her age?
>> But also LD true is a see now now like here guys like
right here. Now this is the kind of thing that's really harmful
to people. Okay, calling this guy
this guy who like totally shares around nudes without consent.
This guy who records people without their consent. This guy who
who very much just doesn't care about the age of the young women
he's texting with. Okay, it be the real harm isn't any of those
things.
We need to move on to the Connor stream to you but realistically
like >> mapping the destiny drama virtues vices and relationships.
Valor reacts aliens. Okay. I don't know why that is what this
is but okay. We'll listen to Connor. This is from three days
ago. All right. It's from three days ago. This is the Connor
stuff. I think we watched the first little bit with Perry, but
I can't remember where we drop off with the Perry stuff. Okay,
>> this to white knight for Lauren trying to do good >> somewhere
around here. I'm going to hit play on this. I'm going to use
the bathroom really quickly and I'll be right back. Okay, I'll
be right back. like I already started living this way and he
articulated something that I had experienced to be true but had
not articulated in my own brain >> which is that purpose
um horrible miseries of life
can be embraced or endured if you have purpose
and then purpose
is also correlated with
Okay. So the more responsibility
that you have in your life, chances are the more sense of purpose
you have. And so I embraced purpose. I embraced responsibility,
which is why um despite floundering in academics, I took my academics
seriously. I completed my bachelor's. Um despite kind of being
a piece of um I knew that I wasn't done with security service,
so I became a law enforcement officer because let's be true.
Uh, let's be real. There's there's no job on the planet that
has more responsibility than being a law enforcement officer.
Um, I got married because I did
um
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Um, sorry. Sorry. I'm trying not to get distracted
by chat, but there's plenty to engage with in the chat right
now. Um, but I
Excuse me.
But, um, embrace I I got married. Uh, I found my wife. I actually
became celibate for a few months and I was like, I'm not dating
anyone until I found my >> I don't know what blood is yapping
about. We I accidentally started this on Connor yapping time.
Okay, Connor Story Time was where we started it. Let's see if
we can get past story time. At least according to Steven's critics.
>> When they were interacting, when Steven and Rose were
interacting, she would be 17 years old. Now,
the reason why obviously that repels a bunch of people, I should
probably build a mind map for it, is because there's like the
17 and 364 days meme, right? where like you you you engage in
activity with a 17 uh 17-year-old in 364 days or you engage with
somebody who's 18 years old in one minute and you're a one minute
and you're a normal person the next which I find totally cringe.
Like I I find totally stupid. Um, I actually agree with an old
clip of Stephen
where Stephen says, "Oh, I'm I'm so here's the thing. I think
that's what happens to a lot of people, right? You find out that
they so in the case of actual,
okay, I won't say Desi's like actually for sure a cuz obviously
like it's the primary attraction, all the definitions or whatever,
right? We don't have to like colloquially on the internet. It's
totally fine. It's totally within how people use that on the
internet to call them. Okay. in terms of the academic definition
is probably not totally correct. But I will say even if you were
using only the academic definition, you only find out about this
stuff like everybody knows it's taboo. You only find out about
this stuff once somebody is outed. Right. So for somebody most
people who you find out are literally
you will find out they will go from normal people to in a second.
>> Yes. In a in a second. 28 and a 19-year-old. Just come
back on whatever you're reallyating
15y olds and I think that's super immature and stupid and cringe.
I agree with old Steven, right? I agree with old Steven that
a 19-year-old, it's not that a 17-year-old 364 days and 18 minutes
person can't be physically mature. However, they're still probably
incredibly mentally immature. They're still probably incredibly
emotionally immature, which is going to bear out in a moment.
They're probably still incredibly experentially immature. And
so you just being a little judgmental as a 35-year-old man should
not be interacting with people of this age bracket because they
should be figuring out how to grow up. They shouldn't be with
40-year-old men who have already, you know, banged a thousand
people. They should be engaging with other 18 to 20year-old people
in order to go to school, in order to find their job, in order
to find their husband, in order to decide whether or not they
want kids. >> yeah, we all know why it's bad. We all Destiny
laid out these arguments far more eloquently than you did, Connor.
Okay, just pull up a Destiny clip and let him lay them out himself.
He understands every part of this. Connor, >> an 18-year-old
18 to 25 is supposed to be figuring. >> He just thinks
he can inject himself and like listen, what is this? What is
this 17-year-old supposed to figure out for herself? No. What
is she supposed to ask for parents? No, she talked to me. That's
he's injecting himself in there, Connor. He thinks it's totally
healthy. >> And if you're a 40-year-old who's engaging
with an 18-year-old, you're robbing them of that experential
path where they can figure out everything out on their own. >> Right.
So, that that's been the dynamic that I judge it. So, uh, when
it comes to Steven, >> I I also still want to know, Connor,
what do you think of Steven within, you know, knowing this person
for a couple weeks? What do you think of him leaking all of his
DMs with Lauren Southern, including the name of Lauren Southern's
kid that she is trying to keep secret? What do you think about
that, Connor? What do you think that level of uh what do you
what do you think Destiny's thinking there when he's engaging
with somebody he knows is like barely legal, right? And he is
sending that information to them. >> I think he has a different
framework. And as a result of that different framework, he socially
and excused interacting with what he thought was an 18-year-old
and then a 19-year-old who was engaged in work, which further
complicates the dynamic. The reason why this further complicates
the dynamic is because allegedly how they met is that Rose was
on Twitter.
>> Uh I've asked him this hypothetically, evil Johnny Bravo.
I don't know if I've asked him directly. >> Promotion and
selling content. >> Okay. And so she put in her own bio
that she was 18. There are allegedly DMs between Stephen and
her where he's like, "Hey, you know, your profile was created
yesterday. Can you post some identifying information that you're
actually above age, you look kind of young, and then there's
actually like a follow-up DM in that DM that says like, if you're
not comfortable posting that much personal information, I understand."
And then effectively, she goes, "Well, I can prove that I'm a
real person." And allegedly, again, this is all allegedly because
we have Steven side of the DMs. We don't have any other DMs.
So to me, the fact that Destiny is willing to reach out privately
to Tom Foolery and Counterpoints and correct a whole bunch of
things, but he's not correcting the Twitter DMs to me is very
telling. Okay, because both Connor and Tom appear to be running
with these Twitter DMs as if they're legitimate.
I am more hesitant to run with these Twitter DMs than Tom or
Connor. that now I I still am going to show hesitance towards
them, but until Desessie comes out and says those are fake, I
kind of believe them. I'm I'm kind of starting to like think
that they're they seem to be accurate. >> Um, allegedly
she signs a piece of paper with her like name and the date and
all that kind of stuff to show that she's actually a real human
being. She looks the way that she looks, etc., etc. And in that
DM, it did look like she's trying to sell him. Right. So, what's
interesting about this is that everyone because of this age dispute
where Steven says, "I thought she was 18." Her bio says she's
18. I asked if she was of age. Um, and then I got this kind of
confirmation that she was who she said she was. Um, I didn't
get a driver's license, but realistically, I thought >> I
Dude, can we can we just identify like that right there is like
we woo wee woo, hey, I don't think you're 18. You look really
young and you have a very new account. Can you show send me proof
that you're like 18? and she's like, "Here's a picture showing
I exist." Okay, that's good enough for me. No,
come on, man. Come on. >> Person was of age and so I interacted
with them. Um, this puts us in a weird spot. And the reason why
this puts us in an interesting spot is because Steven, if he's
operating under the fact that she's 18 or 19, I'm going to pull
up the uh going to pull up the law. I live in the state of Florida.
And we're not talking about moral, okay? We're not talking about
moral moral. This is not only cringe. It's obviously like bad
antisocial in my opinion freak gooner degenerate behavior, right?
>> What does Connor think of people who support other people
who are doing freak degenerate behavior that is harmful that
is openly harmful to society? Do you not think that you should
be basically, you know, if somebody's going to do this kind of
behavior repeatedly? Should you continue to interact with them
to boost them to to defend them online? Is that is that really
a good thing to do? >> Just being real. This is
People keep saying that um when I say that Destiny is a social
and arur, they say that that dismisses the seriousness of the
situation. Um however, I'm actually in my opinion, I'm being
descriptive. I'm actually saying that I think that there's something
wrong with Steven uh socially and that made him engage in this
way. But uh Florida and I believe you have a duty to force him
to get help for that if he has a deficiency. If he is not making
decisions of his own free will to do these things, you have to
help get that corrected if you are his friend. Otherwise, you
are enabling harm by defending him. Right? If your friend was
actually a and you knew that and you were like, well, you know,
like I'm just he hasn't offended like recently and I'm going
to be friends with him no matter what. And then he touches your
kid, you're a you need to be taking to a psychologist. You need
to make sure he's getting help. You need to make sure that this
is like registered and understood and getting fixed obviously.
>> State statute uh child
production and distribution penalties. Oh, and possession. I
think it's all under the same statute. So, >> what do I
want counterpoints to do? To not go on like Destiny's podcast
to not like openly defend Destiny on all of these things. To
not basically say like, "Yeah, I understand he's bad, but you
know, Trump's in in the White House." Right? He has he has his
own leverage there. Here's the
interesting thing about the legalism. Again, there's all these
definitions, okay? Whenever you have a Florida state statute,
Stephen lives in Miami. I live in Orlando. Florida is close enough,
right?
Um, so if you get down here to past definitions,
a person is guilty of the use of a child in a performance if
knowing the character. Oh, sorry, let me read the definitions
part. Child or minor means any person whose identity is known
or unknown younger than the year of 18 years of age. Okay. So,
already we have Rose allegedly when she's 17 creating this content
and and she is under the age of 18. Okay. Um, then there's some
>> remember when Zia scolded Tom Fury, Connor should do
that to Destiny. I mean, I'm sure that could happen, right? >> Some
other stuff here about intentionally view performance promote,
>> but that doesn't meet his standard. Actually, Stermovic,
I understand that you are mentally disabled, but it does meet
his standard. It's met his standard in the past. He is he has
far more heat than lollycons than for his friend who is literally
at a minor. Right? That's the issue. He thinks any amount of
normalizing of or normalizing of any paraphilia that targets
people underage is harmful. But he will not criticize Steven
the same way he has Quean for platforming food shops.
That's the
>> Battery beastiality conduct performance simulated. Uh
I think you guys can read those on your own time. But >> he
took the time to go on Chud's stream and chastise Chud. Has he
done the same thing for Destiny? >> Reading the statutes.
A person is guilty of the use of a child in a second performance
if knowing the character and content thereof. He or she employs
authorities or induces a child to engage in a second performance
or being a parent, legal guardian, or custodian of such child
consents to the participation by such child in performance. A
person who violates a subsection commits a failure of the second
degree punishable as subsections blah blah blah blah blah. >> So
what's interesting about this is the fact that So >> we
might skip past this. We'll see. I'm going to listen for a little
bit. Okay. And we might skip past this. >> Who did this?
Okay. The person who did the leaks was dating Rose when she was
17 and allegedly encouraged her to hook up with people from their
local college and high school. Well, I don't know if high school,
but from their local college. And as a result, he effectively
promoted and created sex content. Right. And so, as a result,
he committed a second degree felony, which is effectively something
that can get you 15 years in prison. Right. >> Next one.
A person is guilty of promoting a performance by a child when
knowing the character or content thereof. He or she produces,
directs, or promotes any performance which includes sex conduct
by a child, a person who violates a subsection commits a felony
of the second degree.
>> That sure sounds like uh when you dump those those videos
in that group chat after being told she's a minor, even if you
don't necessarily believe that person, that sure sounds like
what happened there. No. Well, right now both Rose and Solo by
misrepresenting her age allegedly online and selling. >> Also,
why are we applying Florida statutes to them when we know they're
not in Florida would be a question I'd ask. Why are we doing
Florida statutes and then applying it to people we know aren't
in Florida? >> Graphic content on Twitter. They are guilty
of the substitute. So, they have both. Rose, you know, I get
it. Steven's bad guy, piece of them. He whatever. He's a monster.
Blah blah blah. Right. But whatever whatever guys you want me
to say, right? Um they are more guilty in this regard. >> Um
they are. Yes. Yep. I totally agree with them. They're more guilty
in that regard of these things.
I totally agree with them on that >> where if they commit
a felony of the second degree, this is punishable by 15 years
in prison. Right. So there we go. Um I think four is another
iteration of this. But um let's take a look. Um it is unlawful
for any person to possess with the intent to promote or photograph,
motion, picture, exhibition, show, presentation, or presentation
which wholeart includes CP. The possession of three or more copies
of such photograph uh represents or presentation is primmaash
evidence of an intent to promote. A person who violates a subsection
to commit a felony of the second degree punishable. >> Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. The possession of three or more copies
of such a photograph motion.
That seems like one we'd also get on >> as blah blah blah
blah blah. Um, so if Stephen was like, "Hey, if he knew that
she was underage and said, >> Destiny seems to have knowledge
that she's a bunch of different guys and filmed it, how did he
get that knowledge?" He, "Hey, I'm going to sell this stuff.
I'm going to spread this stuff. I'm going to send this to all
my friends." Then he's in as much trouble as Rose and whatever.
But I don't think that's the case. That's at least not what he
has said. No, it said the possession of three or more copies
of such photograph, motion picture, representation or presentation
is primaasy evidence of intent to promote, which again, what
is the definition of promote in this statute? I'm guessing promote
would be what happened in that Discord group chat if it exists.
And then here's the statute that's most important. Um, it is
unlawful for any person to knowingly possess, control, or intentionally
view a photograph, motion picture, exhibition, show representation,
image, data, computer detection, or other presentation in which
hole in part he or she knows to include CP the possession. And
and here's the thing. He or she knows
knowingly.
And so this is where Stephen has DMs
and showed me that he says they were having like a private DM.
It was totally unrelated. It wasn't >> Okay. So he has
DMs that show this.
>> I have DMs that show in November of
Destiny is informed by the producer, who he believes is the producer
and trafficker of this girl, that she was a minor. So, where
is the where do we fail on the knowingly part here? He was
He was informed. >> And the DM says, you know, uh you know,
I'm sorry that if it seems weird that I'm like talking to a 19-year-old,
um you know, and and I'm confiding all this stuff into you, but
realistically, like I feel like you're a good person to talk
to. And then Rose doesn't go, "Oh, I'm actually 17." Or, "Oh,
I'm actually 18." Turns out I lied to you earlier. That's not
the response from Rose. Now, maybe there's a different response.
Maybe there's different DMs. I don't know, right? I don't have
a Discord. >> Okay, hold on. Hold on. This is 8:47. This
is transmission here. Hold on. Let's pull this up. Transmission
of by electronic device or equipment prohibited penalties for
the purposes of this section. Minor means any person less than
the age of 18. Transmit means the act of sending and causing
to be delivered any image, information or data from one or more
persons or places to one or more persons or places over or through
any medium including the internet by use of any electronic equipment
or device. So he has transmitted and she is a minor. Notwithstanding
subsections 8478470113.
So 8470128470133
any person in the state who knew or reasonably should have known
that he or she was transmitting child as defined in this section
to another person in uh in this state or in another jurisdiction
commits a felony of the third degree punishable as provided here.
Right? So this is the issue is is reasonably should have known.
Can Destiny argue that despite what this person said, he had
no reasonable expectation that she could be a child? Right? You're
literally told she's a child by the person you believe recorded
these things.
Can you claim that you have no reasonable expectation that that
could be the case? I will just be >> That's what this is
going to come down to. In my opinion, >> Riyle donated
$3. Okay. Destiny is evil theory 10x. Did Destiny send the video
to the group chat just to create 10 unclean hands to ensure their
defense is comma slash get them in trouble? >> Uh, possibly.
I think Sean from Potentially Criminal covered this specifically
with uh President from the Appeals Court saying they don't care
that the person said they didn't know. So that's the 11th Circuit
in Florida, which says they don't care if the person didn't know.
Okay. Now, I think he talks about the Ninth Circuit. I actually
DM'd him on Twitter about this, so we'll see if I eventually
get a message back from him. Possibly. We'll see. Um, but I I
believe with the
with the 11th
circuit in Florida, that's not the case. With the Ninth Circuit,
they've said, "Oh, well, knowledge like having knowledge matters,
but that the bar is really high." And I do not think Destiny
necessarily meets that bar. The bar should be like, "I had no
reason. I had zero expectation." Right? Like I got given an ID.
I checked that ID and there's no reason to believe. She never
said anything. Nobody ever said anything to me. Okay? That's
that's where you'd be going on on that end. I think as soon as
Solo tells you, right, that she's a minor. I think as soon as
you have that that suspicion, you've you've lost your um your
protection on the knowing thing. Now, that's not to say that
I think that he had to believe Solo, right? I don't think he
believes Solo. I I didn't believe Solo at the time, but unfortunately
for him, like when when when it's like uh when the difference
is being embarrassed a little bit that she went to the cops and
showed you had weird DMs and like it actually she was 18 and
it was fine. Between that embarrassment and oh, it actually is
child need to take this cops take this to the cops immediately.
Like on the 1% chance Solo's correct, right? Even if it's 1%,
it's probably higher. But on the 1% chance Solo was correct,
I think you still go to the cops, right? You don't you don't
risk
you don't risk holding child for months on the off chance that
like it's not a problem. That's insane,
right? Because that's what happened. If we look we look at the
old meme here, the old meme that exists. Okay, his excuse is
I cannot delete this stuff because of my court cases, right?
But when we look at the meme here from a couple days ago, right,
you're told on November in November 2024 that she was underage,
right? Yep. and Pixie filed her lawsuit in January 25 2025, correct?
That's right. That's a two-month gap, right? Yep. So, you deleted
all CSM from your computer. I have a legal obligation to preserve
the videos. No, you did not. Okay. You at best had a legal obligation
to inform the authorities immediately. That's and and there was
no legal obligation. You didn't have a a notice to preserve evidence.
You didn't have that. You didn't get that until January, right?
You didn't >> logs. Maybe it's all Maybe it's all a smoke
screen. But Roa says, "Oh, yeah. You know, it's okay. I think
it's normal to look for people to talk to whenever you're feeling
down, right? >> Oh, hold on. We got uh we got some donos
coming in. Let me uh let me go with these real quick. Okay, Adam
55867,
thank you very much for the 10 gifted.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Massive 10 gifted. Thank you
very much. That's going to add another hour to the stream. You
love to see it. Okay, we got another hour added to the stream.
Uh we had gifts from Machico and Anonymous earlier. Thank you
guys very much for your support. Appreciate both of you. Individual
gift subs. Love those. When did Andy B get involved to advise
Destiny to not delete it? Uh, I don't know that he's ever said
Andy B explicitly told him that. The it's for court is also BS
because the CA uh because the case is over what Destiny sent
to Rose, not what she sent to him. Uh, that could also I don't
know why he'd have to preserve the files that Rose sent him,
right? Although maybe there might be an argument that you could
that you you delete that stuff and maybe there's a chance that
somehow they turn that on you. Maybe there's some argument there
if it's you could possess. Now, we can watch the potentially
criminal stuff after this. From what I understand, potentially
criminal Shawn potentially criminal is saying that this is not
possessible by anybody. It's not even possessible by officers
of the court, right? It's only the state that can even prosecute
these cases. You basically can't even do civil cases on this
stuff, right? You pro there's probably some way you could sue
civily with like testimony from police or something, right? But
you cannot be the person uh Adam, thank you for the individual
sub as well. You cannot be the person who has this as a part
of an unrelated civil case. Pixie can't even view it as evidence.
You cannot transmit it to Pixie. That is illegal. Transmitting
it to Pixie or Pixie Pixie's um attorneys is illegal.
That is also illegal. The only person who can possess child in
the state of Florida is the government. So you can't even give
it to Pixie's team to receive it. So you're saving it. Uh, also
potentially criminal said there's a chance that this actually
screws Destiny over explicitly because he will have to delete
all of it, right? He will have to delete all of it and that will
also be spilation.
So, because he can't possess it, he has to delete it and he won't
be able to present it as evidence, right? And the judge could
easily say, you can look at that as unfavorably as possible,
including that maybe it's Rose sending like retransmitting back
to him that video or something, right? Like like it could be
looked at as almost anything. Yeah. like, oh yeah, and he won't
be able to provide it in discovery. And yes, there's like a chance
this actually him over and he has to settle the case according
to potentially criminal. Maybe we'll get into that if we watch
his stream later. And so within that, it at least correlates
with the narrative that Steven's going with that she lied about
her age. And so as a result, um I still view this morally as
not only objectionable, but perfectly criticizable. Um Steven
should catch heat. He should suffer uh social consequence. He
should suffer some level of reputational damage. he should um
you know pay for his sins provoke u um proverbally. We all reap
what we sow. >> I'm just going to put this up for people
to read. Will from Texas, thank you very >> Um however,
I I don't until we have evidence that he knew. >> Dude,
if he ends up if he ends up having to settle the Pixie because
he he did this, bro, that would be crazy cuz like obviously they're
going to keep on going with the case, right? But if he has to
settle because he can't provide the evidence, that would be hilarious.
He didn't have a court order twisted rope. That's the thing.
He didn't have a court order when he had reasonable suspicion
it was CP.
That's the problem. >> Knew that she was underage. Um I
don't think that he's going to face a criminal penalty. And if
uh he does face a criminal penalty, I expect him to talk to the
state attorney and say, "Well, she lied about her age and she
and Solo did all of these things. So if you're going to prosecute
me, I think they should be prosecuted as well." >> Gonna
say that to the state attorney. Connor, you need to switch over
to the federal statutes. Connor. Conor, switch to federal, Connor.
Okay. Uh, also,
how does that help Destiny?
Your honor, what about Solo? Your honor, what about Rose? Your
honor, these people also had child. Your honor, your honor. Your
honor, they had child, too. Oh, did you like find them? And can
you point those people out to us? No, actually, that was people
at Kiwi Farms who found her identity, and I didn't really help
at all there, but uh Oh, wait. I only helped them a little bit,
but realistically Oh, but you want you want like help for that,
your honor. As Hassan said Hilo is a valid military target. Does
that not does that not do anything for you? >> And then
Jaki Queen the Kiwi Farms Army, your honor. Your honor, your
honor. >> The state attorney is going to have some choices
to make, right? So, anyways, I kind of wanted to start with that
because I think that's where we're at from the legalistic analysis.
Um, even if you don't believe me. Yeah, Connor is just conveniently
ignoring things, right? And Destiny has to do this. Destiny has
to maintain that he had no way of knowing, that he had no reasonable
suspicion that she was under 18. I think the issue is that's
why he's doing the whole confidence man thing, right? He has
to show repeatedly that he is confident she's 18. He has to lie
about this. Even though it's obvious to anybody who's looked
at the evidence, any one of us, somebody like Connor even, that
when Solo tells him she was under 18, it doesn't matter that
he thinks he's lying. He now has a reasonable expect. He has
he has some reasonable understanding that that could be child
and there is only one option at that point. There's only one
option. I do find this extremely like morally objectionable for
a 34-y old man to >> right then he has to go and start
re-evaluating those DMs from the lens that she might be a minor
and then those red flags we talked about the braces her parents
not letting her fly out like that that has to start jumping out
right like massive red flags jumping out of those DMs and you
go oh I actually probably do have to go and do this I probably
do have to go to the cops but you know what solo did worse guys
I want you all to remember that Solo did worse that as bad as
Destiny is, Solo is worse. And that somehow means anything, okay,
for for Destiny not being prosecuted here, >> an 18-year-old
worker. Um, and I do find it objectionable uh to basically accept
the lie of an 18 or 19-year-old worker and then just engage in
behavior that's extremely risky that ultimately, let's face it,
it's his career, right? this whole thing, the whole thing of
being with Molina but wanting to be with Lauren and
uh talking to Rose at the same time and spreading new tapes and
tapes around. I would go back to there's this kind of infamous
stream from 2022 where he's >> It's crazy that Connor totally
leaves the the non-conceptual recording out as well, right? Just
has to totally leave >> and he's talking to Molina and
he's talking about the Max Carson and Lavlin drama and he says
like, "Oh, I have uh my life is under control. I'm actually living
the healthiest life I've ever lived. I'm actually uh loving everything
that I do. I wake up and I love my life. Everything kicks out.
And while you guys are saying that I'm doing the equivalent of
skydiving every single day, this is how I want to live my life.
There's some level of risk to everything. This is actually like
uh this is actually like a almost it's not verbatim, but it's
a pretty close quote to what he said to Abba and Molina when
they were hanging out in Miami. And I think Abba and Molina are
like, "Dude, you're living in this." Like even Molina, who who
by the way is also promiscuous and also in open relationships,
um she was like, "Dude, you are flying way too close to the [__]
gun. you are absolutely gonna get burnt by your behavior. Um,
Aba reinforces that too where he's like, "Yeah, you're you're
gonna [__] tort yourself. There's no way you can
sustain this level of behavior without reaping some kind of horrific
consequence." And uh, Steven now 3 years later is still reaping
the consequences of his actions in 2022.
Um, so that's kind of like the legalistic and moral analysis
of the drama as it stands. Luckily, Destiny proved all of them
wrong.
Guys, I'm Connor. Does that not concern you that Destiny was
like, "I'm living the most controlled, safe life I've ever lived
in 2022 while this was happening." Does that not concern you
that when you come on? Uh, I believe Connor went on after this
happened and he said, "Don't you agree with me that like I was
correct about your lifestyle spiraling out of control?" Did Destiny
say yes or did he say no? Cuz I could have sworn Destiny's response
was no, you're wrong. You just don't understand. I do want to
map out what I think are like moral foundational differences
that um separate what like myself from Steven. >> I don't
care. I super don't care about this part. Moral foundational
differences. If I believed Connor was capable of maintaining
any moral moral foundation, I would care about this section.
Why would I believe anything he says here when the moral points
he's laid out would lead to him disavowing and distancing from
Destiny like multiple times over the past couple months? Why
do I care about anything Connor has to say about his morality?
His morality is flexible. It bends with the wind. He is basically
Sneo but twice as old. Okay?
Like I actually can't see a significant difference between his
morality and Sneo's morality where it's just a leaf in the wind
all over the place. And then I think we need to talk about like
well what's the appropriate response? What's the appropriate
punishment or consequence or whatever? Because a lot of people
are just saying like oh well Stephen or Steven they say Connor
oh he's such a bad guy. You just need to burn him instantaneously.
like you just need to end your relationship, call him a piece
of [__] backstab him, all that.
>> You've stated your principles, Connor. You've stated
you stated you'd have to distance yourself from anybody doxing.
You've stated that you did, Connor, >> as many times as
you can and run away screaming, but I would say that's not in
my temperament. Uh that that's not really in my uh behavioral
outset. And um so as a result, I kind of want to >> Dude,
does anybody even need to like I don't need Connor to I'm just
saying you don't have morals. You obviously haven't distanced
yourself, right? you. But yeah, I don't need you to like I don't
need you to go, "Oh, Desty's the worst. I'm never doing content
with him again." But probably if you just keep going to his house
and hanging out, it looks a little weird. I don't think there's
any reason to think it wouldn't look weird. >> Like these
things. And then um you know, we we'll make a choice. I'll tell
you the I'll tell you like my choices, right? Um as we articulate
them and um some people have some interesting comments um and
I'm going to go through chat. I'm going to respond to the super
chats. Uh I'll try to read as many chats as possible, but then
I do want to highlight like the moral foundations difference.
Actually, super chats have a different tab. Um, Fast and Bulba
says, "Remember, we wouldn't have this drama if it wasn't for
MTV's The Real World." That might actually be true. Uh, McDevon
says, "Hey, just wanted to apologize for Singing up the chat
yesterday with my RTR party argument. It was not my intention
to provide cover creeps in chat, though that ultimately was the
effect." Uh, McDev, I it's not a big deal. Lightning in chat.
And so, my apologies for Hammer stuff. Absolutely. Pages worth.
He says, "So, under the law of this MS, uh, barely any different
from Matt Gates?" Oh, hell no. Uh, weirdly enough, I think Matt
Gates knew though, so there actually is a difference. Send Patty.
So Connor is only defending the um the the acquisition of the
child to begin with. I would say that if Destiny had gone to
the cops immediately when he knew she was under 18 because he
had this like this uh
right I would say that we'd be in a different position. I think
>> he says that's wild that the solo guy is getting away
with this stuff. Yeah. He actually at least according to the
law he created promoted and sold uh illicit Teeny Tiny Tony says
guys look how bad how bad the solo guy is. He's a real evil dealer.
Don't look at Destiny. He's just a dumb goon. See, teeny tiny
Tony, you're actually going to get banned. Not because I'm not
open to criticism, but because you're misrepresenting what >> I
I I could just immediately say the solo guy did worse than Destiny
did. If um if he's like um well, probably not even if I'd say
probably you have to hold a 17-year-old responsible for for making
and and selling child porn, right? Like he probably did do worse
now.
Maybe there's an easier path path to redemption for him because
he's not as set his ways. He's very young, obviously. possibly
like gets tried as a juvenile or something, right? Or if he'd
been caught at the time. So, we don't know anything about that
guy. Uh it seems like the actions on their own, you know, he
he recorded with Rose a bunch of uh child, right? And then he
sold it. That that seems pretty easy to just go, okay, yeah,
that sounds bad. That sounds worse, right? But now those two
don't have a platform. Those two aren't, you know, engaged with
all of these other creators in like in like drama, in wars, and
all of this other [__] these these two people also
haven't harmed significantly more like a bunch of other creators
in this space, right? So, realistically, we just say that they're
worse than Destiny and then we can move on because they have
no further relation to this. We don't have to say every single
time these guys are worse. Why would we do that? They're not
the people who have been embedded in the space who this entire
space, this entire Twitch politics space has been built around
over a decade, right? So, I don't need to I don't need to go
and say solo's worse every single time. It's pointless. I can
just say Solo did worse than Destiny and then we can move on
and talk about Destiny and and like this thing that we're all
surrounded by, right? Seems pretty obvious what I've said. I
didn't say don't look at Destiny. I said let's look at Destiny,
but let's also look at the facts of the matter. This is actually
going to be the number one thing that's going to piss me off
or frustrate me is when people are like you're ignoring the problem.
It's like no, I've described the problem in accurate detail as
>> I would say. So going forward, we'll just watch. It's
very obvious to me
that you can talk about Solo the one time when you're doing your
overall analysis. If when we're going through this and we're
we're going to say, uh, I want you to condemn Destiny for the
X, Y, and Z. And he goes, well, you would condemn Solo, right?
That's disingenuous. That is sweeping at that point, right?
Accurately as I possibly can. Jennick says, "Lol, I thought about
this yesterday." Interesting. Twin says, "Bab Destiny wishes
he was in the Irishman about now. I don't know what that means.
Nobody's defending solo. I didn't ask you to defend or attack.
>> Okay, hold on. Apparently, Jacob wants to come in and
ask about some timelines changing on Destiny's side. I don't
know what this is going to be.
I don't know what it's going to be, but he's in waiting room
and he wants to come in. I swear you better fix this time.
>> Come on, bro. Come on, bro. >> Hello. Sorry, I
was just stream. >> Can you hear me there? >> Yep.
I Oh, it's it's whatever. It's >> Okay. Uh turning off
some AC. Um, has Destiny
previously to the last week been saying that like all the content
was with the boyfriend? Am I misremembering
>> I don't recall that. I recall saying like different
guys or something. I recall him talking about like different
guys or some [__] >> Okay. I just I feel like
the trafficking claims are kind of crazy to me. Like if you're
seeing someone who looks pretty young in like a hotel room with
like lots of different guys and like now you're like, "Damn,
this woman was trafficked. We should be really going after Solo."
you probably should be like knowing this is a trafficked woman
and like throwing questions
uh regardless of whether you find out they're 17, right? Like
that's kind of crazy and he's like self-reporting
>> Maybe the claim is that the boyfriend was always recording
it that the boyfriend was recording all of the content but
potentially.
>> But like I guess the the like she's being trafficked
thing like if you believe that then like you probably should
have believed that this whole time, right? Am I just being like
a hater looking for things or is that like kind of reasonable?
>> Well, I would say I would say it seems like there would
be the same complaint there almost certainly, right? Like like
you'd have to think the same thing. It's like in in the same
way that they go, "Oh, well, you can't just find out she was
17 and a half and call Destiny a It's like you can't just find
out she's 17 and a half and go, oh, now everything that happened
to her is horrifying,
>> Yeah. Like >> like obviously it should have seemed
probably horrifying before that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. The only reason I'm aware of like the trafficking
stuff and the reasons that it seems like trafficking are cuz
he just dumped these now where he's like it's like 10 different
people in hotel rooms. Like I'd never heard this before. >> that's
like crazy. Even even if she's 19, that's like a crazy thing
to be hearing if it's like being like solicited through like
a long distance. Like that sounds pretty crazy. I don't >> that
like
hotel room thing. >> Where's the hotel room like log or
>> Um maybe uh I don't have that log. Maybe maybe I'm even
making that up. Like it if she's talking to her parents. It wasn't
at home. She was a 17-year-old that wasn't at home. >> Yeah.
Maybe. Maybe not. Maybe I'm Maybe I'm corroborating that in a
wrong way. I feel like I remember hearing that, but I don't have
a way to corroborate that. >> Like, yeah. I don't know.
The claim just
>> the trafficking claim just seems really crazy to bring
up and act like, "Oh, wow. You guys aren't like more upset about
Solo for trafficking this person." When like I >> I had
no >> Oh, you're lying. >> No expectation of that
being even a possibility until he mentioned it. I'm like, "Oh,
hello. Hello. Am I clear now? >> Uh, yeah. Go back like
10 seconds. >> Okay. Yeah. Um, I just I had no concept
of the possibility of trafficking until he brought it up. And
like if you're bringing that up, I feel like you should have
been aware about that for quite a while and probably had some
issues with it and maybe reported that. >> Uh, I kind of
agree with you that I think he probably should have been more
aware than he was. I >> I would have to find like his actual
claim, his description here. >> Even if you um even if
you verified an ID, like let's assume he'd even checked your
ID. If you're like thinking it's like um being trafficked, like
damn, that's pretty weird. Even if she was like 18, that's like
pretty weird. And there probably should have been red
>> I don't know. It's just there's a lot of stuff that
is pretty gross and icky and feels like it >> he's just
like digging a bigger hole by trying to push back. I don't know.
>> I don't really have any here. I just
mention it. >> Sure. Yeah. I think that's um that's interesting.
Maybe we'll look at that uh like building that out more. Uh that
idea I'd have to go find
Hold on. Porter builder saying um he said in a stream we tried
to find what hotel when he was talking about the group chat he
made to find her. Yes, I think that's correct that he talked
about that video being at a hotel.
>> But we'd have to go find that. I'm guessing those streams
no
fine. Otherwise I'll do. >> Cool. Appreciate it. >> Yeah.
See you.
All right. We're back to Connor content. Okay. Content.
Wait, that's already content. This is the word content.
>> So, yeah, you guys are just like making How credible
is this evidence? No idea. Yeah, don't make up positions. Uh,
Schween says, "I thought it was known or unknown. Not according
to the statute." So, at least what what I'm reading. If you have
a different statute, I'll read it. But a dude saying, "I'm so
glad you're of age is kind of expected." No. Uh, I have no idea.
See, I think this definitively proves D isn't paid by Israel.
Otherwise, the Assad guys in the walls would have to wipe all
the revenge point keeps getting. Thank you, bro. Thank you, bro.
I needed >> Why was he asking DJs to find her if he knew
she was over 18, though? I mean, that could be to to possibly
go after Solo, right? >> Says, would the girl just take
a quiet LOL about what if it was true and he didn't know? What
would be your take and what is your final line? Uh, I don't know.
I don't know. I think I'm figuring it out right now. Conservatism
says seems to been sitting with three other people in a room
with red carpet acknowledging that tweet hashtag was being used
for people promoting CP. There's also several tweets of Rose
using the NSU hashtag. I don't know what that is. I am not online
or >> I would say the NSFW teen hashtag is when she used
and
>> enough to know what you said. Has two Has two wrongs
typically been a very good defense in your time in law enforcement?
No. No, it hasn't. But
this people keep saying lack of knowledge. >> Is he going
to critically engage with that? He uh
>> you're going to have to
>> No, a lack of knowledge is a defense. Um in some places,
right? It is a defense. Uh you have to defend why he's going
to say he had a lack of knowledge after being informed directly
that she was a >> Tell me a different statute. >> Now,
I would say for me personally, it's like here here's the question.
Okay. If you're 1% sure that you've received child porn, is that
worth going to the cops about? What percentage chance do you
just risk a child charge because it's so inconvenient and it's
such a low probability that you just say, you know what, I'll
tank it if on the 1% chance that it's child, I'll just tank those
charges. And then you you also go and apparently take pictures
of these videos and send them to other people. Like I think for
most people that percentage has to basically if there's anything
right 1%.1%
001%. I feel like if there's anything there for a lot of people
they're like oh yeah that that
that. So what did I do? Florida state statute. And for the 50th
time this is not a moral analysis. This is a legalistic analysis.
I know [__] women got triggered over that. Uh Florida
like like we'll get into the morality. Don't worry we got time.
We'll talk about morality. We we'll go for three hours about
morality in just a second. uh Florida state statute uh child.
So um you can I'll just open this up and just see uh what that
one is. But the possession
>> it is unlawful for any person with intent to promote
any photograph. You're going to have to show Steven promoting
it. I think in order for where it says
>> possession of three or more copies of such photograph
motion picture representation or presentation as screen of fash
evidence of intent to promote
>> we're going to have to I think there's a a sub thing
up >> hold on hold on Conor's getting there I think. Let's
see >> here that basically says that like different from
a different source actually is part of the calculation. Um so
I'm not a lawyer so take all this with a grain of salt. However,
um 5A is going to be knowingly possessed.
>> But four would be its own charge. No. Wouldn't four
be its own charge? I thought 1 2 3 and four were all different
ways you could charge the same crime that they're all chargeable
under the same statute. No. >> He or she knows. So um I
think it's immoral. So So let's be clear. I think it's immoral
for a 34y old to contact an 18-year-old in 1 second. An 18 year
and 1 second girl who's selling her on the internet, a 34y old
can buy her because she's 18 years old and 1 second old. However,
I find that that's legal. I find that immoral
and stupid.
Uh conservism. So him asking for a deed, but settling for written
acknowledgement that she's 18 shows he just went a plausible
deni and he was playing with fire. Uh playing with fire for sure,
but I think you're reading in a level of intent that I don't
have sufficient evidence to agree with. Two bits says wolf ignorance
is worth just a slap on the wrist. That's some weak. Okay. Uh,
is that a valid defense? Uh, I am open to you guys saying Google
substitute XYZ ABC. It says something different. As a matter
of fact, we'll go ahead and do this. Uh, possession promotion
of certain images of CP reclassification for purpose of the section.
Child or minor means anybody whose identity is known or unknown
younger than 18. This talks about that the term may not be construed
to require proof of the actual identity of the minor. Say massic
abuse. This is all definitions. >> Okay. I might want to
look up what Connor's looking at. Just a second. We'll see. We'll
see. We'll see. We'll see. I just got to link this tweet. Let's
go. Uh, hit him with the hine.
>> I've been thinking about that that situation a little
bit more. >> Let me go to top of this. >> I don't
regret distancing myself from something that was very radioactive.
>> It's hilarious how absolutely terrified you are giving
any actual any input of actual substance on the Destiny is
cowardly too scared to let go of the engagement you get from
his audience. You're a weak piece of [__] with no
morals and this is the biggest proof of all. Okay, what was this?
Your boy, they got your boy on CSAM charges. You goofy. If the
standard here is that you parasocial psychos are still going
to do a pathetic guilt by association charge many months after
I stopped associating with Destiny, boy, do I have some bad news
for you. Oh, this is so close to the right to the correct approach
from
Um, I just want to point out I don't do the the guilt by association
thing. I said I thought Hutch did a very good statement with
regards to Pixie. Very human, best one out of that entire Lib
and Learn crew. And when he talked about forgiveness, the only
thing he up was that Destiny has shown no contrition. He's shown
no apology or sorry, he's not apologized. He's not shown zero
apology for his actions. Right? That's that's why you can't start
down the road to forgiveness because he's not apologized. He's
not made amends in any way. Right? So So that's the only thing
he really up on. Now, I think you could argue he is trying to
um to siphon views from DG. He's trying to like appeal to that
audience, right? But I agree that probably it's it's weird to
do the the guilt by association thing if he's not explicitly
like trying to defend Destiny, which I've not seen him do, so
you tell me. But this is unfortunately the wrong way to approach
it to what about to Hassan is going to set everybody off so hard
that it doesn't matter, right? Just going, "What about Hassan?"
That's kind of an insane response, bro. That's just an insane
response. What about Hassan?
Uh what did Hassan do? What What did he do? He He What? I got
detained and lol overruled has words. So Hassan's friends with
a guy who did some stuff.
Okay. Also, Hassan immediately cut Alex off. So that guy that
they're bringing up. Okay, perfect. Hold on. I just needed the
context for what the the clip was. So this is uh this is him
talking about this >> to consider their own reputation
and their own
>> Sorry, I backed it up. I just need to start over on
the clip. So, it's Hutch being accused of standing by Destiny.
Okay. And and Ogre Boy hits him with the old clip, okay? The
uh the clip of him talking about how he regrets making any comment
on the situation. >> I've been thinking about the Destiny
situation a little bit more, guys. I've been thinking about that
situation a little bit more. I don't regret distancing myself
from something that was very radioactive. Like, every creator
has to consider their own reputation and their own like brand.
Um, that's not a moral calculation. It's just that's like a necessary
calculation that every creator has to make. But >> I think
this was before that was a concern here. Um, even less regrets
it because he was I think it was not >> the only thing
I regret was like talking about it in detail. I think looking
back I wish I would have just put that space and just not talked
about it. >> So I have nothing no problem with it here.
I think he Oh, this clip's going to be too short. I think what
happens here is he kind of implies that some new information
came out that made him change his mind on this, right? That's
where it's like bad because you should actually be specific and
say what came out because it just gives the wrong impression.
Overall, I don't have like too much heat when that fails at Falcomain.
Get him with some of the old pow pow. Hold on. New food shops
clip actual spicy question.
>> Okay. All right. Um, would you be willing to rebuild
the bridge of destiny? Um
>> I try not to take really absolutist positions on anything.
Um I think you know I think the short answer that to that would
be yeah but like it it really just depends on a lot of things.
Like
I want to see
more information come out during this trial. >> Dude, what
is happening?
>> I've had people privately reach out and relay um >> you
ready? So, I don't think that that's necessarily the wrong approach,
but let's uh let's watch Hutch's Hutch responds to Ogre Boy,
and we'll see what he says. Okay, you all claim to be leftists,
but then and then your principles go right out the window if
they apply to people you don't like. You're all entire you're
all entire frauds. This is going to be about it's going to be
about rehab again. Again, all I want to see here is where has
Destiny shown contrition? Where has he shown apology? Where has
he where has he made it clear that he was in the wrong that he
up and apologized and made amends?
Where has that occurred? That's that's the problem. I am totally
fine with you having the position that people can be redeemed,
but you shouldn't talk about redemption for people who have made
no attempt to get redeemed whatsoever, okay? Who have not remotely
done that. I said I had friends in recovery who did horrible
things and eventually turned their lives around. So, I never
take an absolute position on closing bridges with anyone. So,
this would apply to Destiny as well. That's it. I know people
who while they were in addiction, uh, hit their wives, stole
their stole from family members, were generally abusive, etc.,
etc. These people get on a better path and I'll hap I'll be h
sorry and I'm happy to call them friends. Yes, but unfortunately
the better path part is required, right? And you could say, well,
I could I could see forgiving them, but I have to see them get
on a better path first, and I've never I've seen no evidence
of that, right? I think that's what you would do. Um, tell me,
Mr. empathetic lefty, can anyone redeem themselves by taking
responsibility for mistakes and trying to be better? Or are some
mistakes that are so uh are there some mistakes that are so bad
the person who did them deserves to be forever shunned by everybody?
Do you see Destiny currently taking responsibility for mistakes?
I don't. That's why you don't see me collaborating with him.
If I felt like that changed and that was uh and that he was sincere
in his efforts to stop making the same mistakes, I'd be open
to reconnecting. And you're going to tell me that this is unreasonable?
Lol. Get [__] I don't think that's an unreasonable
position. I think he's done a poor job like um making that entire
thing like he didn't include this part, right? Which I can infer
and I don't I don't have to, you know, say that he doesn't mean
that when he doesn't say it, right? But some other people who
have who, you know, people who have been, you know, getting docks
themselves or who have seen other people get docks, have seen
how this is heating up, they want to see that this part is there,
right? So, if you remember when I when I watched this, I was
like, this is the part that's missing. But I I do believe that
he probably knows this, right? Anyway, big hutost. Big Hutch
post. I got nothing to worry about since the truth is on my side.
Also, Destiny, how can how much can I spend on lawyers? >> Oh,
boy. 29 views. Well, it's a reply. It's a reply.
Anyway, sorry. Uh, wanted to take a quick break there. Uh, >> back
to Connor. >> If the offender possesses 10 or more images
of any form of it, regardless of content, and the content of
at least one image contains one or more of the following. A child
who is younger than five, that doesn't apply. Sat massacus sic
abuse of the child, that doesn't apply, I don't think. Battery
involving a child, >> I don't think. >> I don't think
that applies. Beastiality involving a child, that doesn't apply.
Any motion, picture, film, or video, computer generated image,
or video involving a child regardless of length regardless of
whether
um in the case of a felony of a third degree is reclassified
to >> wait. Any motion picture, film, video, or computer
motion film involving a child regardless of length and regardless
of whether the motion picture, film, video, or computerenerated
motion contains sound.
Oh, so it's literally just videos automatically apply there.
Has Destiny got 10 or more videos? Do we think Destiny got 10
or more videos, guys? What do we think the odds are that Desi
got 10 or more videos? He read through that really fast, but
he's saying I don't think any of these apply.
The content of at least one image contains Oh, wait. At least
one image contains one or more of the following. Oh, this is
definitely there, right? That there's a film, there's video involving
a child. So, like it's over.
Is Connor is Connor not like do you notice how fast he ran through
that? And just is he going to imply that that doesn't count?
I think that counts. So this is what we talked about. So Sean
said when he was on Kino Casino, uh potentially criminal said
that he has seen cases in the past or he's heard of it where
they take the frames of the video and count that as individual
images. Not for individual charges, but for like charges like
this, as in like if you have a video and there are multiple frames,
that counts as like 10 images, right? >> The second degree.
Okay. So these are enhancements. Um, if I'm reading this correct,
these are enhancements where if these things apply, you effectively
jump to the next level of punishment. I don't think these apply.
So, you guys are going to >> uh that that last one almost
certainly could apply. >> Have to show me an alternative
to
subsection 5A. And again, purely legalistic. We'll talk about
more in a bit. Teeny Tiny says, "From the DMs, it doesn't it
does seem that he didn't believe her listed age was real." Okay,
prove that in court. Your honor, I had doubts, but I didn't verify.
again.
>> Okay, prove that into a court. Then what the [__]
is the purpose of having this conversation, Connor?
Why? Why even have this conversation and pretend you're going
to engage in any kind of hypothetical or something? Okay, prove
that into court. Huh? Wait, wouldn't you just make an argument?
>> That was some generational cope. Uh, if you're talking
about the ABA stream. Yeah, AB and Destiny got 100% on that part.
Can't lie. Yeah. Oh, but to point out that he shuts it down.
Lol. I miss Abba. Me, too. Destiny isn't skydiving. He's driving
by the school and hooking up with kids, hoping he can convince
everyone around him who thought all seniors were 18. Uh, again,
I feel like uh that's uncharitable, but you don't have to be
charitable. Uh, Teeny Tiny says, "Destiny cheated on Molina and
lied to her about it, too." He even lied about it to their uh
if you're talking about Lauren. I don't know what was said to
whom. Um, but I think that Molina said that part of the reason
why their relationship didn't work out was because she allegedly
Steven lied about the the
>> No, Molina also went around showing like a bunch of
DMs to a bunch of creators showing that he was lying. I I believe
>> of his relationship with Lauren. says destiny turned
out to be a serial gunner a turned out to be a racist smell turned
out to be arl but what a timelineween says well what is your
line I don't know let's talk about morality in a second um Jenn
time about wet lord southern rose yeah says destiny only stuff
in the mainstream zone audience is pretty friendly established
sure but we should still have moral judgments about bad behavior
this is what I don't like I I feel like the overly critical Destiny
haters are like disavow him now but then I feel like the Destiny
supporters are like he'll survive no matter what
says I'm surprised cover this to be honest I mean truth be told
if I didn't cover this I would have 50 people today who are just
like cover this cover this cover this cover this Um, why not
just respond to chat live? I mean, I am, but I I'm normally 20
minutes behind my chat. Teen Tai says, "No, that's what you imply
by focusing on things that aren't relevant." They are relevant.
They're relevant.
>> Couldn't you also argue then that basically all child
is relevant and you shouldn't focus on Destiny because there
are other child in the United States that you could focus on?
Like if you apply this logic and you just like run it out, right?
Then uh okay, well, there are other facts that are relevant.
It's like, well, Solo's not relevant to me. almost at all. Right.
I can acknowledge that he did worse, but now like he's not relevant
to me anymore. I don't care about him. We just move forward.
No. >> Destiny is pain for stupidity. Hope he learns his
lesson. I agree. Helps even just dropped a Hillary Clinton glaze
vid. Uh oh, that's bad. Dice says 150 viewers like the stream.
Yeah, dislike the stream. Dislike the stream. Richie Harrison
says, "It seems like you're working through your morality pers."
Well, let's let's talk about that, Richie in a moment. Hype for
the morality section. So, some chick lied about age. How's that
Destiny's fault? Lol. Right. I I feel like you're both I feel
like the Destiny simps are being too dismissive about the seriousness
of what happened. I feel like the Destiny anti fans are being
too like he's should be like I think that's crazy.
>> Yeah. Uh ABBA is a lazy and he always does lazy research
for his videos. He is so bad at his job. But it won't matter
cuz he's kind of cool and kind of funny. But ABBA in terms of
actual like accuracy for his research, he's a total [__]
He uh he presented a bunch of BX bullet research as like like
he didn't understand what she was even claiming. He like totally
misrepresented it and tried to show that like the government
is paying to get the the manosphere killed and it's like okay
okay good one good one. Yeah. Uh ABBA is funny and the content
is good but when he does something that requires like actual
research he is a total and doesn't make sure he's correct on
anything. Little says I'm not online enough or degenerate enough
to know what the hashtag was either but someone DM to me that
there's a Twitter thread that explains it all. Gotcha. includes
Stephen saying that was the hashtag that was used for and showing
rows used to promote herself if it's a standard garbage being
pedled under posible deniability garbage. I'll link it to you
on Discord. Gotcha. We can be mad at all these losers. It doesn't
have to stop and started Destiny. Right. Uh Gen X says, "I check
federal statutes in the middle of the night because they were
in different states. I've tendency same requires knowledge or
intent making distributing doesn't." Yeah, >> I know Destiny.
I don't know Rose. I don't know Solo. That was so easy to just
understand. Connor, do you know Rose or Solo? Yes. No. No. Oh
well, let's move on then. We can agree that they did really bad
things. Probably worse than what Destiny did. Can we move forward
now? >> There you go. Great doesn't require intent. I also
checked Kelly Cali because I heard he lived there but I don't
know. Right. Why don't you ask for his side before speculating
me? I've already been but I'm catching up. His side is that she
lied about her age and he didn't know that. That's his side.
You mean immoral like how bad baby made a million dollar in 24
hours on her 18th birthday? Yeah. Unir unironically. Jedax all
the all the critics can say oh you know Steven's like a but this
bad this bad baby thing is like 100% legal right where people
thought Bad Baby was attractive before she turned 18. Then she
turned 18 and people gave her a million dollars within 24 hours
just for being attractive.
Right. Andre says, "Do you think a 30-year-old guy hooking up
with an 18-y old is immoral? I think it might be bad for you
to be promiscuous at that age, but I don't know if you're taking
advantage." Okay, so we we'll get into that in the moral section,
but effectively, in my opinion, I I think we'll be able to articulate
it. I'll make a different graph of actual like maturity. I know
that's like an edgy topic, but I think it's worth discussing.
And I think there's a difference between let's say you're 35
years old, you're serally monogous, you've dated a ton of people,
and you just haven't found your wife, right? You haven't found
your partner, you haven't found somebody you love, and then you
meet somebody, they're 18 or 19, and they're incredibly mature
for their age. That those people do exist. Um, I know it's probably
a joke. I know it's cope. I know a lot of 35-year-olds might
be like, "Oh, she's 18, but she's so mature for her age." You
know, that's probably just cope, right? But let's say that one
out of 10 times or one out of 100 times it's not cope. And the
35-year-old just genuinely falls in love with an adult girl who's
18 or 19 who's mature. They they share, you know, ambitions.
They share goals. The age gap doesn't bother her. Um, the age
gap, the type of guy to pull up the states on how many men hit
their the stats, sorry, on how many men hit their wives to call
it normal behavior. I dude, it's I don't know why he's making
this argument, right? This is, by the way, this is just the less
the more palatable version of Vos's argument. It's actually possible
for a child in an older man to have a relationship for that to
be beneficial for both of them. He's just doing the same thing,
right? He's just doing the legal only version of it, but it is
just the exact same argument. >> Yeah. Kind of bothers
him, but maybe not too much. Um, and so as a result, they start
like a genuine relationship where they're trying to get to know
each other, support each other, etc., etc. I don't have a beef
with that. what I have a beef with is and this this might come
across as tired of Stephen, but you know it is the way that I
feel. Um I >> obviously he's never approached a relationship
with a 19-year-old or 18-year-old that way. Very obvious. >> Do
you think that there is a effectively a fish in a barrel kind
of thing with like Leonard DiCaprio and characters like that
who are there are men who are established who are 35 to 50, right?
And so instead of looking for their life partner, they know that
they can find young people who are interested in money, who are
interested in clout, who are interested in power. Um, and they
might be willing to transact for money, clout, or power. And
they >> Connor story time. Thank you. >> My thing
is, um, >> if I miss something that's important, guys,
you go ahead and let me know. I know some of you were watching
the stream the other day. If I miss something important, let
me know. I just know Connor story time is going to get really
boring and we'll have to cut some some time out. >> I'm
going to spit these things out at the top of the head. Off the
top of the head. I'm going to say them as I see them, not as
they're accurately true. So if you have an objection to me describing
my morality or describing Destiny's morality that's fine. Uh
but effectively let's you know let's get into it I guess who's
calling you out exactly Destiny anti fans. So um so I think that
between nihilism like idealism
um and like like theism and all that kind of stuff like all the
ways to perceive the world I think I'm an absurdist. Okay. And
what I mean by that is I think that the world is a confusing
terrifying silly weird space. And so the world can be so absurd
that I try to look at it with like a sense of like ironic cheer
where even if the entire universe doesn't matter, it I'll I'll
find some level of meaning with within the the chaos of the universe.
Then um I also think that I am a uh what would I say like a a
Burkian conservative
which means that where does the religion come in? We follow the
holding in Hicks v. state that the defendant's ignorance of the
victim's age is not a viable defense to the charge of you of
a use of use of a child in a performance.
This is Florida. Yeah, this is the 11th district court of appeals,
right? So, this would be the one that Sean talked about earlier
>> You defer to rather
>> defer to existing institutions but listen to critics/p
progressives. And so, what I mean by this is like
um what I mean by this is the church sped up. Give me the the
church is to some degree an absurd institution, right? The the
church has been around for 3,000 years. Uh if you include the
the Old Testament, it's been around for like 4,300 years and
it's steeped in all these things like let's chop our dicks off
and if you're not willing to sacrifice your child for God, are
you really a believer? And uh we have like all the Greco Roman
struggles with Jerusalem and all this like crazy [__]
right? Um David, who was a man of God, he's a man in the Old
Testament. Uh the way that he proved himself to be a competent
warrior, is he ran around uh in the land of the Philistines,
modern Palestine, and he people and he chopped their tips off.
I'm not kidding. Like that's actually the story of David, King
David, one of the greatest kings of Israel, is that when he was
proving himself as a warrior, he just ran around killing Palestinians,
Philistines, and and chopping off their hips to prove that he
he killed them. You know what I'm saying? Um so that's ridiculous.
However, um I try to understand it as a context of whether it's
time and its place. And not just that, there's concepts like
the Old Testament, right? Uh, you know, honor thy father and
thy mother. Uh, you know, you you'll put no gods before me. You
know, uh, thou shalt not lie, thou shalt not murder, etc., etc.
And so, I try to find the value in these things while constantly
accepting progressive stuff. >> I'm going to put mild social
>> Let's just uh
uh anti- degeneracy,
anti- aivopile, anti-olicon, pro- maximal ordered freedom, mild
fiscal conservative. Okay. negative.
What does What is Hold on. What? >> But Steven has never
actually said like he's four creepy dozen children. Um, a
negative, I guess. I would just say I would reference some Mr.
Girl >> Why not reference his actual stated preference
for 15year-olds and thinking they're hot? Why wouldn't you just
go with that? I don't I don't know why we He was an adult. He
like quadrupled down on this 15-year-old in the bikini being
super hot in his DMs. Why do we have to go past that? >> I
will just be your pig.
Hold on. >> Reban Ruben donated $3. I guess he wasn't in
it for the money, just the tip >> in David Banger. Thank
you very much, Reban Rubin. >> Lollcon
apologist. And so the reason why I'm putting this though is because
Stephen, maybe maybe I'll put negative neutral. The reason why
I'm putting this >> just put neutral >> is because
of consequentialism.
And also when uh what is it? Uh when uh Bosch got into like huge
amounts of trouble. Is Destiny a consequentialist? I thought
Destiny explicitly was not a consequentialist. Well, >> for
the lollycon discourse, Stephen was like, "Wow, wouldn't it be
nice? >> He is okay. Okay, he is a consequentialist. This
would be my this would be my own uh misunderstanding of >> You
had a debate bro friend who knew how to make lollycon arguments
and when everybody was like, "How do you feel about it? Where's
my hyonic treadmill?" Absolutely. Hadonic treadmill.
>> I don't need a whole lot more of this. >> God,
you guys are gross. They will make excuses and arguments for
why you should be able to engage in that behavior. And then Hadonic
treadmill is effectively like uh
by her
>> I I'm sorry. I feel like I could just come back and
reference this. I can take a bit and come back and reference
it.
>> Biblical passage and it basically says like if your
life sucks out, it's probably because you're doing if your life
is good, it's probably because you're doing good. And Steven
all in all has a materially very good life. But I think spiritually
and socially, I hope he's willing to admit that while he's had
a very rich social life, 15.
>> We're going to go with the Connor. Let's
>> uh you know, I would want them to contend with what's
being said. So, let's go ahead and throw up 0 to 10. >> This
is the This is the Connor psychoso sexual development chart.
Okay. He's going to list ages and explain I I assume why these
people are viable or nonviable partners. >> Let's throw
up 10 to 13. Let's throw up uh 13 to 15. Let's throw up uh 15
to 18. >> Do we have to, by the way, do we just have to
go find like a Connor conversation with Mr. Girl? Because as
much as I don't remember those happening, I feel like it had
to have happened at some point, he must have talked about him.
And I feel like he would have had criticism for engaging in these
exact hypotheticals. Let's throw up 18 plus and let let's codify
our morality because this actually is something that like frustrates
and piss me off is people blending. So, a child is technically
a person, a minor. It's somebody under the age of 18. But people
are saying that because Steven sent messages to somebody who
claimed to be 18 plus, but was actually 17, he's equivalent to
somebody who has with somebody who's 0 to 10. That's okay. As
I've already admitted, does it meet the dictionary definition
of No. But on the internet, we all use this definition. And I
just be interested to know if Connor himself was calling Mr.
at some point cuz it feels like and again it just feels like
that would have been the case but we we don't know yet. Okay,
we don't know yet. >> Crazy, right? So anyways, let's do
this. So in my opinion and I'll solicit feedback from chat but
effectively 0 to 10 uh caps lock
uh should be uh maybe I would say functionally
right uh should not have relations with each other. Adults should
not interact. Adults who interact
slash com uh have compulsions to should be treated as let's say
uh I want to I want to look up the definition of paraphilia real
quick. Paraphilia definition paraphilia is a term psychology
that refers to interest in atypical objects situations or fantasies
that deviate from what is considered normal or social acceptable
behavior. These include fetishism, exhibitionism, voyerism, sadism.
Okay. Uh yeah. So I think I think paraphilia works. Adults who
interact compulsions to should be treated as paraphilic
freaks and should be socially ostracized
slashleally prosecuted as appropriate. Does anybody have any
objections to this classification? Like I I know that like there's
edgy people and and all that kind of [__] but this
is actually what I believe is that if you have a compulsion to
engage with a with with somebody who's from 0 to 10, you should
there's nothing
I think there's nothing to complain about yet, right? Like this
is just obviously true effectively be treated like the overall
situation that he's creating this chart to argue these definitions
explicitly to defend Destiny to to say it's wrong to call Destiny
a right.
I think that's funny in and of itself, but in terms of the zero
to 10 >> a [__] freak. And if you have that
compulsion or impulse at any moment, you should effectively say
that's a bad part of my brain. I'm not going to indulge that
part of my brain, right? Okay. So, it seems seems like we're
largely in >> Is there going to be anything interesting
here in the 10 to I don't want to skip it necessarily, but is
there anything interesting 10 to 13 to 15 going to say possibly
early development can talk to each other? Oh, >> Scroll
through that real quick. I am actually going to let him say it.
I'll let him say all of the things. I don't want to I don't want
to actually predict what any of these these things are. I'll
>> she was 19 and has an only fans lure. Uh this is a four
out of 10 at best.
>> She said she's 19 and has an only fans. Where did she
say she isn't only fans? Like this is the part this is another
part of sweeping by the way. If you simply never actually look
up or learn any of the actual information underlying a situation
and you let people in chat tell you what things are with no push
back and no understanding that can be sweeping. You are just
a useful for these people. Right. Where did she say she has an
only fans? I I've not seen that log necessarily, but she did
not have an only fans. She factually did not have an only fans.
She said she was 19. I also don't know where she said she was
19. Right. So Connor could be going like, "Can I get a source
on that?" Right? But he's not. He's going, "Okay, I guess so."
>> Chat real quick. She said she was 19 and hasn't only
fans. Lol. Sure. Uh, this is a 4 out of 10 at best in terms of
bad. Uh, sure. But at the same time, that doesn't mean that we
don't acknowledge what's bad. Rob says, "If we're recreating
the path from being born to in the late '8s, then your 10 to
13 should include midnight infomercials for girls gone wild playing
after late night Fox sitcoms." Uh, sure. There's certainly a
choice to do this one live. Certainly, no one will try to clip
J. Yeah, but you know, the truth is the truth, right? Wood chipper.
Sure. All good so far. Seems pretty fair. Makes sense to me.
Um, add in future court starch for zero to 10 offenders. Sure.
If we're hyper liberal, you'd probably want to not exile those
people and maybe encourage them to get help. Sure. Sure. If you
have like a more obviously I think I'm like more to be socially
that the novel will lead over the lives of um under the age of
three. Hold on. Let's get things uh physically
or or you know pet kiss
at the end of the day right >> now. Now maybe this is like
overly prudish for me. >> Labeling the act
how I feel about it. Um should be ignored by the rest of the
population. Um, if an adult uh maybe like I don't know what,
like a Yeah, if an adult interacts should be viewed as a paraphilia
and socially ostracized legally uh prosecuted as appropriate.
So that this is where I'm at. So any objections, any any additional
notes? We can add punishment for adults under each category 0
to 10. Oh yeah, that's what I read. Connor says, I disagree and
I think you're missing something. You say 18 to 35 is gross bad,
but 17 roughly 18 is legal, so who cares about 17? I mean, I
care. I didn't mean for that to be around 0 to 10 years old.
Haha. Personally, I think 18 and 25 deserve to get jail, too.
That's just just isn't the law. Um, sure, but let's not like
overly paternalize. Not going to lie, this is weird. Be back
later. All right, cool. You might have missed like two hours
of Sure, but let's not like overly paternalize. Not going to
lie, this is >> Be back later. All right. Okay. >> You
might have missed like two hours of discourse prior to this.
This is why they don't teach morality 101 as a course. Sure.
Just that people need to >> Why is this necessary for Connor
to do? Because Connor has to explain why he thinks it's not um
that insanely immoral for Destiny to step on this line. Step
over this line, right? He's got to explain why these lines are
really important and why stepping over this line does not mean
you can call Destiny a It is wrong and inaccurate to call Destiny
a and if you step over this line, you're the one in the wrong
and you're actually giving cover to the people over here who
are actual.
He has to be able to do that, right? So, you have to draw this
whole chart out, right? That's what you got to do >> to
dislike the stream. True. Or like >> the only reason to
do this and I The only reason to do this is because you need
to defend Destiny overstepping this line, right? >> Okay.
You can dislike or like. All right. All right, if anybody has
any objections, I'm not seeing any objections. Uh, I think this
is appropriate. This is where the individual has a time. They're
physically, emotionally, and spiritually immature. Peers can
have handhold dates, go to the movies, pet kiss at the end of
the day, should be ignored by the rest of the population. That
way, they're not predated upon by the rest of the population.
If an adult interacts, it should be viewed as a paraphilia, socially
ostracized, legally prohibited as appropriate, right? I think
that's appropriate. I suspect the high end of 10 to 13 is where
that would be reasonable. I think that a lot of people want to
move it to 10 because apparently there's some people who start
puberty at like 8, but I still think 10 is probably appropriate
for most kids for for um like the beginning of you don't have
to be talking about like graphic stuff, right? All right. Anyways,
um 13 to 15 um I would say still immature handhold dates
plus 2year age gap. I think that's about right. I think most
Romeo and Juliet laws are uh 3 years, but I'm just going to put
two years for like my judgment. If a 17-year-old is dating a
15-year-old, I normally think that's [__] weird.
If a 15-year-old is dating a 13-y old, I think that's [__]
weird. If a 14-y old is dating a 16-y old, I think that's weird.
But at the same time, like, I'm not gonna like I don't know.
I'm not gonna send a 16-y old to prison for dating a 14-y old,
>> Why does he think that's weird? >> That's what
we're talking about. >> Yeah. Oh. Oh, my wife just called
me up. Connor, why are you engaging in literal debate right now?
Connor, why are you talking about when 13-year-olds can right
now? Connor. Connor.
Mrs. Counterpoints suddenly not really enjoying Twitter. I'm
not going to send a 16-year-old to [__] prison for
dating a 14-year-old, right? That's what we're talking about.
>> Yeah. Oh. Oh, my wife just called me a She was 19 and
I was 24. That's pretty funny. Um, oh, >> immature handhold
dates plus two year age gap. Um, I don't know. Um, adults
uh shouldn't wait. If an adult interacts, should >> it's
like weird evil Johnny Bravo, but I don't think it's really that
weird to the adults, right? It's weird to the kids because it's
a huge gap in in difference for the kids, but I don't think adults
think it's like that strange or care that much. >> Viewed
as paraphilic
depending on age.
>> You guys think it's weird when like a senior dates a
freshman? You guys think like adults think that's weird? I don't
know if I think I don't know if I agree on that, but okay. >> App
Well, 18 to 15 is still kind of paraphilic. Um, >> I don't
think that was the case when I was a kid, but maybe >> if
X should be viewed as uh potentially
slash abusive
like 1815 1815
as limit. I would say 18 plus should be like off limits. 18 plus
should be off limits and viewed as predatory. Uh, Tanner stages.
No, I haven't looked that up, but that's interesting. Really,
I feel like high schools mismatch all the time. They do. They
do. Um, high schoolers do mismatch all the time. Uh, however,
what I would say is I actually, maybe I'm overly prudish, but
when I was 16, I wouldn't date anybody younger than me because
they were >> uh, Kuryoko, I believe this is explicitly
not illegal in a lot of places.
I think like quite a few places in North America have a 16 age
of consent to begin with without like a Romeo and Juliet exemption,
but >> sometimes very immature. Uh, what age is it okay
for you to defend Desty sliding into minor DMs? Never. There
there's no there's no way. >> I was doing the 16 and 18
evil Johnny Bravo. That's what I was thinking about. My bad.
>> Yeah. My wife called me out because we have a 5-year
age gap. But I met her when she was an adult. Okay. Jesus Christ.
But Simo says, "Has looked at the tages yet?" Nope. But we will.
Or 357 and DMing too. Yeah, that's uh I would say that's pretty
pretty bad. Do you think Seattle uses dog ears? Gen X says, "When
I was 16 to 17, I dated a guy from church that already graduated
college. He came to my senior pro and was friends with teachers.
My parents wanted me to marry him." I would say that's kind of
rough. I would be asking why if he was 20, if he was like 19
or 20 and he got through college first. >> Huh. I would
be like, "Okay, that's not like too rough. >> That's rough.
Just throw it in a chat." Um, if he was like 22, 23 chat >> and
you were 16. I'm going start to put my eyebrows up. You know
what I'm >> AK B says, "Put the 12 to 14 year olds in after
school activities in team sports and get them to rebooks and
play games. They don't need to be dating." I agree with that.
>> Um, I agree with that. I'm going put that down. Um,
should be academically
to parental supervision slash uh supervision slash advice. >> Um,
adult interacts. Uh, sorry. Um then
I would say Romeo and Juliet laws which are basically
uh 2 to threeyear age gap and then adults who uh date this age
group should be viewed as potentially
and then for me uh what is it? >> Okay,
uh should be academically
focused for to prepare for adulthood. Okay. So, I haven't seen
anybody like popping off and saying like anything crazy like
I think 13-year-olds should be able to have a 10-year age gap.
I haven't seen anything crazy in my chat. Um, aka better choice.
Many parents can't afford that. We can't even agree on paying
for guaranteed school lunches. Sure. Why would 25-year-olds go
after people who can't drink, right? Jennick says he was 23.
That's a little tough, bro. I'm I'm not going to lie. 23 like
23 and 16 is uh that's pretty tough. I would say that like your
parents like if he's a nice guy and he's a sweet guy from church
and he wants to wait until marriage and all that kind of stuff,
then I would be like, "Okay." But if he was like >> I can't
believe how how much Connor kept the memes out of this. Okay,
the memes are all in like the fact that you have to He just did
this entire thing. He walked through this entire thing and the
only purpose of building the chart is to defend Destiny going
from this category to this category, right? Is to say that ah
it's not that bad. Ah, it's not that bad. He didn't know. He
didn't know. He didn't know. It's not that bad. Ah, it's not
that bad. >> Hey, Jen. What's up? Let's hang out. >> Well,
while also saying no, it is bad, but it's like it's like
17.9 and 18.1 are the same. Then why are you why do you have
a line here? >> Let's drink alcohol. Let's go to this college
party. I'll be like, "All right, that dude's [__]
up." Um, Colin Kale says, "There's always something to be said
about gender age. The girl should be the older one, but I don't
think that happens very often." True. Senpai says, "Like tell
them you don't touch grass. Without you, you don't touch grass."
True. Uh, that is so weird, Gen X. What the? Yeah, Gen X. That
That's a little tough. Astronaut Pharmacist just got done with
leg day. Now I'm well prepared to suffer. As not teens need to
be dating because make mistakes early on will be easier for them
to learn as long as they know he gets pregnant. Sure. Well, he
was in seminary college after that, so I guess religious people
are just weird or were 30 years ago. Yeah, it was probably uh
Sacred Snow says, "I can't believe we banned all the lolli
>> Connor is a bad person." Uh, I'm starting to get there
that Connor is a bad person. I think this is mostly a performance
for money. Um, now I I think I think like I have I understand
people do lots of different forms of performance for money and
so there's like some conversation to be had there. But in Connor's
end right now, it's like after this stuff, the stuff he's like
defending is just weird to me. Right. I would say like
if this was your friend and this was the only thing they did,
I would almost understand, right? This is a really close friend.
It's the only thing they did and you wanted to say like this
was not that big a deal. The problem with Destiny is we have
like a decade of behaviors that fit in this like nexus of uh
like bordering on social on predatory. It seems to be like with
a focus on plausible deniability, right? Like dude, it all fits
in the same like Nexus. He just seems like a pretty bad person.
And when he is enabled, when he has this platform, when he has
the clout to go and like get these sex relationships, it seems
like a lot of people get hurt. He's not responsible in any way,
right? Like that's what Connor's enabling and continue to enable.
So I think that's like that just seems like where you have to
draw the line. It's not over this one behavior over any one of
the behaviors that Destiny's done. You can defend any one of
those behaviors as like an individual thing in a vacuum. But
when you pile them all up, and that's why you have to address
the the pattern of behavior, right? Because when you pile them
all up, you start to realize, oh, this guy's like a horrible
[__]
Oh, it's the again. Took JShock years to disavow Destiny. Now
it has been a few It took me a year of streaming. Took me a year
of streaming. I've been in the community for like a year and
a half before that. It's just weird. You're making like really
weird arguments. I'm like not equivalent to any of these people,
but you don't know what you're talking about. Uh, I think you,
Stermovic, can just go back to Queman. Okay. I think I think
Queman enjoyed having you on his stream. You can go back over
there. Um, or I or I I'll say 25 bucks. 25 bucks for an unbanned.
If you want to pay money to be in the chat, that's okay. 25 bucks
to be a in the chat. That's cool. >> Orders from the guideline
stream. They need to be here for this. Nice. Nice. Nice. Conor,
how do you feel about cases where an 18-year-old is dating a
17-year-old? I get that it's technically illegal in some places,
but I don't frown up on that. No, I actually think that in most
jurisdictions, Romeo and Juliet laws apply. So, I think that
there's typically a 2 to three year acceptable age gap. Um, when
I was 22, I thought it was icky to date 18-year-olds, especially
if they were in the 12th grade. Imagine having sex with somebody
and then helping them pack for school. Bruh. So you're saying
Hallelujah is icky and your views engage with the narrative of
the novel classic and you're here power ranking acceptability
by group page. Yeah, actually unironically true. He started hanging
around my family when I was 13 years old. Yeah, King Stylo unironically
this guidance prohibits Lolita
13 to 15. She was 13 years old. She's still physically, emotionally,
spiritually immature. So I think the the argument is that Lolita,
which I've not seen, is actually like an exploration of how older
people exploit like lines, like social lines, and how they can
be creepy while maintaining some plausible deniability. Like,
isn't Lolita actually like a criticism of that kind of relationship?
Isn't it meant to be creepier than like it actually would be?
So realistically, it is like a critique. I I've heard that's
the argument. That's like what it's about, right? Lolita is a
novel and then it was turned into a movie. So again, I haven't
seen it. I've heard that's the the the whole point though is
to show that like these things are bad and and to make it seem
like creepy and and expose it expose that kind of behavior. That
girl should be going on handhold dates with people that are within
her 2-year age gap. If an adult interacts with her, it should
be viewed as paraphilic or abusive. And I would say like an 18-year-old
would be the limit that I would allow a 15-year-old to date.
18 plus should be viewed as offlimits and predatory. They should
be focused on academics and extracurriculars focused to prepare
for adulthood. Do you have any um specific
>> Sounds like the argument for Cuties. I think that could
be a good argument for Cuties if Cuties wasn't using underage
girls in the actual filming. Right. If Cuties used adults and
tried to make them look young, that would be one thing, but I
think they actually used children. They actually said children.
I think that's where you get an actual criticism of Cuties. King
Stylo, I would love coming from Queen's community where like,
you know, he makes excuses for lollycons. I would love to hear
your objections. King Stylo, please hit me with your objections.
Hickardell says, "I think you're in your >> Can a child
Can a drawn child be harmed? Connor. Connor, I'll give you the
the super easy line for most people. Can a drawn child be harmed?
No.
Oh, well, I think we found the huge difference, the massive gaping
difference between actual and lollycon. Cool. >> Reason
you hook up an 18, 23-year-old, you meet at a bar club, a little
weird frown upon. Anyone dating on that age gap is absolutely
insane. Yeah, that's actually where I'm going to go next. So
dude, I'm just going to say um
if you're 18 plus, you're an adult and figuring it out slashmaking
mistakes is a part of growing up. I would say 5year age gap.
Um now here's a very interesting thing. Why does the chart stop
at 18 plus? Aren't there a bunch of major developmental like
uh developmental hurdles that you go through after 18 that would
be worthy of including on here? Right? like it stops at 18 plus
and that seems like an interesting choice to me because it's
Connor doing the whole thing that he totally disagrees with,
right? At 18 plus, well, now it's just free game cuz that's what
the law says, right? But he said his own morality doesn't feel
that he doesn't feel that way. He feels like it would be just
as wrong for Destiny to do this if she was 18 and 1 second versus
younger. So why does he stop at 18 plus would be a question.
is okay.
But if a uh 23-year-old
exclusively dates uh 18-year-olds,
look out for predation. And then I would say uh exclusive dating
18year-olds
uh could be predatory. Uh I don't know what else you guys want
to add to that. Um that's kind of where I'm at. And then what
would be the next thing? Uh kind of like uh love,
true love plus marriage uh can overrule
the age gap. And just as um as an example, somebody said their
uh dad was like 33 and mom was 24 or 23 or something like that.
Um and they they're still together. You know what I'm saying?
So again, >> yeah, but 33 and 24 is almost defensible in
that you're usually over your last major humps at 24, right?
Like this is weird.
This is weird, but I don't think that 33 and 24 is like even
close to anything else we're discussing here, right? that person
24, they're out of college. They're in like a different light
stage of their lives, but it's not it's not a stage that's definitely
>> Objections. We have any objections? The worst is where
the dude who pick their girlfriends up from school. All I see
is Woodson from days and confused. Yeah. Um Ash says, "I dated
an 18-year-old when I was 16. She was a senior. I was a sophomore
in high school." Yeah. And I'm sure that was fun. BC says, "Why
did you call Stylo awe farm yesterday? Is he not?" Uh yeah, that's
sus. Kings says, "4-year-old should not be dating 18-year-olds."
Uh yeah, bro. That's why I said 2year age gap and it should be
viewed as potentially paraphilic or abusive. Aren't you coming
from the community that does apology for >> Hold on
fast. Hold on. Should not be dating apology for lolly. >> What
are you like? >> Hold on, >> bro. You're team food
shops now, buddy.
Apologia for lollycons.
Destiny raided a lollycon while that lollycon was viewing content
of his minor son. What community are you a part of if that's
not supporting lollycon? Bro, I'm thorn between all boys, all
girls schools, but also literally social class period so kids
can stop turning out so aspie. Yeah, I agree. How old is food
shops? Didn't they want to wrap themselves around a 12-year-old?
Yep. You're breathing down Charles L Queen's next platforming
food shops like two years ago. And now that she's on your side,
you're saying, "G, I hope she moves away from being about lollycon."
Yeah, that's true. I hope she stops being a lollycon. I hope
Queen stops doing apologia for lollycon. >> What? You see
how flexible the spine is? Do you see it? The spine just totally
he did a pyouette. His spine without leaving his body did a piouette.
Isn't that incredible? Isn't it incredible how that works? >> Conor's
not a fan of food shops. He's repeatedly said that. True. Your
pay master is rating food shops with like four times Queen's
viewership. Yeah, that's uh bad.
>> Did you get on his stream and go and and do a whole
song and dance about how that is and how it's totally morally
reprehensible? Connor, did you do the whole song and dance, Connor?
The same one you did with Chud. >> Do you have any objections
to what's being said? Did you just say 23 and 16 is okay as long
as he's a nice boy that is in two years. Everything else is okay,
but was insane to me? Yeah. Um, so
>> wait, if Destiny I just want Connor to tell me honestly
if Destiny actually a 10-year-old, would you just go it's bad
and then you'd move forward? It's bad. Nothing changes. It's
bad. Nothing changes. It's bad. I I The cops aren't prosecuting.
Okay, Connor. The cops aren't prosecuting. You know what happened?
Do you just say it's bad and move forward? Oh, it's bad. That's
pretty bad, guys. That's pretty bad. I think that's pretty bad.
>> The 16. So, I was trying to make an exception for Gen
X so she doesn't feel weird about her thing. Um, but realistically,
like I think that's weird as I think I think setting up your
daughter with a 23-year-old is weird as I I think the only reason
why that would be like acceptable is uh if he was like and basically
uh Gen X did say that he ended up going to seminary, which means
he's probably some level. Conor, is it true you control 100%
of your wife's finances? Uh, yeah. Yeah, because I make all the
money. It's true. >> It's true. the only stream I feel
is >> It's a That's a crazy question from Perry right there.
You have to understand Destiny is going to save American democracy.
Apparently, yes. Despite the only thing that Democrats and Republicans
can agree on is that people predating on kids is the the worst.
Destiny will save America by making constant jokes while having
credible allegations that he has maintained a stash of Seam in
his own possession for months. Okay. He is going to save America
doing that exact same thing. Cozy to watch. Not true. Which is
worse though. DG does Lon apology of plat platforms food shops
destiny DM kids but yeah other community is bad I guess yeah
plenty of other communities are bad I don't know why these are
mutually contradictory we actually did like a whole uh a whole
drawing I made a drawing for you here it is I made this for you
the moral differences between the Destiny community and the cog
community as I articulated it
has mature quicker I went to Latina Junior high was turtles and
the chicks already had big dot dots well what's interesting coup
is that I had a friend um his name was Nathan he was trying to
convince me that between here and here is no difference and he
participated in the craziest behavior I ever heard in my entire
life. >> All right, I couldn't see his his mouse there.
Hold on. >> Hold on.
>> I saw Lumpy Will. I hope I like this ped chart. It justifies
exactly what I was thinking. He keeps spamming through these
comments and I want to see him. I saw Zezy. This would not happen
if you unban shelf owner. Okay, good one. Zezy, shut up. Are
you going to reassure Destiny to not Are you going to re reassure
her you going to reassure Destiny to not raid food shops like
you did to others who associated with her in the past? I don't
know what he's trying to say there. Are you going to pressure
pressure? Are you going to pressure Destiny to not raid food
shops like you did to others who associated with her in the past?
Yes.
Thank you, Q. Thank you. >> Uh Q, are you going to reach
her destiny to not food shops like you obviously associate with
her in the past? Sure. I'll tell them that's I'll tell them that
having like associating your brand with somebody who doesn't
discon. Yeah, absolutely. All right. Anybody got beef? Anybody?
Anybody got problems? Understanding platform shots is way worse
than queen. Might as well just remote log into desktop. Sure,
I would say so. It doesn't seem like we have any objections.
So, I guess the question is now um how >> looks like uh
potentially criminal Sean just followed the channel. What's up,
potentially criminal? How's it going? >> Oh. Um Ashley
says, "How would you
because her accented to a 17-year-old?" Um yeah, that'd be crazy.
I don't Yeah, I don't engage with any of that. I think that's
[__] impulsive. Conor, you disable bad things. Yeah,
it's bad. Yep. Respect for live sparring. Y said want to turn
into his next Jasan. Well, I guess I'll just kill myself at the
airport then. So, no reputations and all no use. Amazing. I don't
think you forwarded an argument yet, King Stylo. What reputations
refute? What? What arguments have you made? Uh France is not
a loop. Yeah, he rated food shops effectively. For those of you
who don't know, I should probably take this story down when we're
talking about food chops. Um maturity slash uh age uh map. Probably
shouldn't put map. I'll just put maturity age. I think this is
like a reasonable expectation. >> God damn it. God damn
it.
Uh,
why? So, I'm trying to think of how to interact with this because
actually like I feel like I almost need content because Stylo's
not giving me anything. I was actually expecting more haters.
So, Sean says, "Don't know if you've seen that, but Nathan's
message about having a dad was so much more painful than his."
Well, sure, but we talked about that on Monday. Conor, do you
realize how awesome this makes you look? I respect the VA you
have for making a chart. Thanks. I mean, truth be told, it's
an art, but you know, look, we're seeing bad. What do you want
me to say? >> What What ends is it attempting to accomplish?
It seems to be seems to be offending certain people. >> We
all reap what we sow. True. King style says, "You want to engage
with your clear bias that I have outlined, so there's nothing
to say." Uh, okay. I have a bias towards Steven because I consider
him a friend and he's engaged in bad behavior. I'm open about
his bad behavior. I criticize his bad behavior publicly. I >> Has
his bad behavior becoming more and more concerning or less and
less concerning as long as you've known him, Connor? Have you
become aware of more and more like dangerous things? Have you
he become has he engaged in more and more dangerous content the
longer you've known him or not? He's now doxing people. He's
calling for people to get killed. He's directing his fan base
to do violence. Connor, it seems like things are spiraling out
of control and you're not doing anything. You're taking no responsibility
on yourself, which by the way, I don't even necessarily have
moral condemnation for, but like he does. He thinks you should
be doing that, right? That's his position. Like what what are
you doing to slow this down? You're not slowing it down. You're
just staying associated with this guy who continues to become
more and more
>> the same way that I view Chud logic by the way sty like
you're kind of saying like there's some hypocrisy there's no
hypocrisy I think that chud logic normalizing food shops within
space was poisonous I think queenan will admit that his constant
coverage >> Connor not realized the progressive victory
money isn't coming back welcome Sean um you you think that but
because of the connections Connor made through progressive victory
he is now on Valor Media Network getting paid to make content
full-time by a group associated
I believe >> that does like uh I I think it's supposed
to be doing like positive male role model content or something
like >> I can't think of something that's more positive
that something that fits better in terms of positive male role
models than making a chart of acceptable relationships between
different age groups. Okay, it's uh it's kind of goofy
touch media. Jesus Christ
of food shops normalized within the space. I think that food
shops has done a good job of not talking about lollycon. But
if she's still an unapologetic lollycon, she should stop being
a lollycon. Right. Even Chloix has made Stylo King highly malicious.
Also mad for Queenman. You You're mad at Queman right now. I
thought you were best friends. Jenn is just
Also mod for Queman. Mod for Quean. >> Even Chlo has made
Stylo. >> Oh, that's
also mad for Queenman. You're mad at Queman right now. I thought
you were best friends. Jenn says just unbanned everyone who was
banned yesterday. Yeah, that would kickstart the discourse. Tanner
scale. Tanner scale. Okay, let's look at the Tanner scale. Tanner
scale. The Tanner scale, also known as Tanner Staging or maturity
rating, is a system used to assess the He's been given like a
six-month window to make something of his viewership or he has
to go back to a regular job at J. Really? They just gave him
a contract like, "Hey, if you can hit some metrics, we'll we'll
keep you." I see. That'll be why he's consistently doing the
Destiny content, right? That'll be why he's engaging this way.
He wants to get another contract to more flush out like the things
he uh he wants to do. I I suppose the ends will always justify
the means, guys. Okay, we'll get there eventually. Connor being
a content creator is good for the world and anything that happens
has to happen along the way is a justified sacrifice. All right.
Jesus. Physical development of children, adolescence, and characteristics
such as development in females, genital development in males
and pubic hair development in both.
This is I think too detailed for me cuz I think with this
they're actually just melting or they're actually just mapping
genitals and breast sizes
and I think that's way too specific. The reason why I picked
an age range is because there's obviously going to be exceptions.
There's going to be like I don't know there's going to be a 13-year-old
who looks like a 16-y old. There's gonna be a 16-year-old that
looks like a 19-y old. There's gonna be a 19-year-old that looks
like a 40-year-old, you know? So, I feel like that's like overly
granular. You will get more push back. True. Not wrong. Bob Ross
of Twitch, happy little pink streams every day. Yeah, sure. Uh,
Assad Whitewatch says, "If Queen Snarkers Kiwi Farms do it equals
morally bad, Destiny does it equals stupid." No, it's still morally
bad. What the [__] Putting Queen and Chud Logic and
Destiny on the same level kicks ass. Um, Chud Logic also DM'd
an underage girl,
right, who lied about her age.
>> Oh,
and when Chudlo Logic found out that she was underage, did he
take all appropriate action to remedy the situation that had
unfolded? Yes or no?
What was Chudlogic's reaction to finding out she was underage?
Because I believe Chud Logic had not received any explicit material
from this person, right? They had flirted. It got weird, but
I believe he not received any explicit material. What do we think
Chud would have done if he'd realize that this person was a minor?
Okay. And he'd received explicit material. Did Ch Did Chud send
revenge to that minor? No, I do not believe he did. I do not
believe he did. Chud does not dedicate a solid segment to laughing
at this loser. He has no balls. Chud just doesn't want to be
involved with any of the Destiny stuff. Okay. It's uh it's a
crazy situation right now. Okay. >> That in typing. Can
I get that in writing? Can I get that in writing that Chudlo
Logic was being a gooner in By I love Chloic. I'm not morally
imputing him at all. Chud Logic was engaged in Discord kitten
behavior. He was messaging a 17-year-old who lied about her age.
They engaged in Gooner chat and he reaped social social consequences
as a result. Right? So, in this case, weirdly enough, there is
some level of comparison. You can say Steven's worst, but in
that regard it's comparable. Yo says I don't think women normalized
her. He did spread her though. >> So you can you can say
you can say that that there's some comparison, but is it a fruitful
comparison? What is to what end are you making that comparison,
Connor? Do you believe we're being inconsistent with how we've
treated Chud Logic and Destiny?
Or are you simply trying to muddy the waters? Are you simply
trying to create a false dichotomy between these two false dichotomy?
No, no, no. false equivalence between these two things because
you want people to criticize Destiny less, right? So, make the
make the criticism because you can't just say, "Well, they kind
of did the same thing, right? Or else you're blatantly sweeping."
That is objectively sweeping Connor. Okay, get the broom out.
Can we get some sweeping emotes in chat for Connor here? Okay.
Or you can say where we're being inconsistent in applying all
the things we think about um about the situation onto Chud versus
how we're applying them onto Destiny. But make a criticism. Don't
just don't just obiscate. Okay. Don't just say, "Oh, well, they're
kind of the same with no engagement cuz then you look
whatever." How is ridiculing and putting food drops on blast
normalizing? That is what it exposed. It Dr. Filia because Queen
normalizes the procon perspective. Whenever somebody says don't
look at lollycon, it normalizes.
It normalizes a female. It normalizes a bad part of your brain.
He says it's just a drawing, bro. So if that's what Queman's
>> I believe Queman's actual position was something along
the lines of hey if you're looking at this stuff do not engage
with like kids in the real world like you have a problem and
stay away from schools and if you only do it in the you total
shut in then I don't really have that much concern but it's probably
enabling something that could be harmful. Oh that's what Queen
said. Didn't you say that [__] says how was he challenging
food shops besides just milking her for content if he agrees
with her morally. QQ says food shops talked about multiple times.
Yeah, then I'll actually uh reach out about that. Interesting.
May have to reassess viewing their content. Yeah. Yeah. Food
shops in in my opinion uh does decent schizophrenic
queen JTO political not political but like personality anti-destiny
coverage. She does decent >> Oh, Connor, could you send
me a segment you think she's done well in? I would love for Connor
to send me his favorite food shop segment. Connor, can I get
can I get a link? I want your favorite food shop segment. Let's
check that out. You tell me how. Man, I would love to see it.
I would love to see it because I think he's just blatantly lying
right now. Okay. I don't think he's ever sincerely watch food
shops. I think he finds food shops disgusting.
>> But if he has if he has some segment he wants to send
along that's really good >> like coverage. But yeah, she's
like a unrepentant lollycon which is horrific. Didn't Chud yell
at food chops? He sure did. When you doing viewer callins show
not today that
my Yeah. Yeah. That wasn't
that. But now the video
talk about David. Yeah, we moral check.
What I do that's on the level of any what what why do I get compared
with with the group of people about normalizing? What have I
done that's even remotely close to food shops?
>> Hello. Lot of balls on the tanner scale. Yeah, apparently
inshots's likely racist. Well, we don't hate him for that, right?
Marco says, "Quickly caught up. Kind of wanting you to expand
on the morals. Where's the line? How can you be sure he'll never
do it again?" I'm not. I think you're a positive influence in
him, but you were unaware of his bad
What evidence is there that Connor is a good influence on Destiny?
Destiny has become more of a degenerate, more of a principalist
loser the longer he's known Connor. There's actually evidence
that Connor might be to blame for Destiny's downfall. Okay? that
whoever Connor is around might turn into just a total blithering
than him being a positive influence on anything Destiny does.
>> Uh yeah, sure. Let's do that in a second. Le let's deal
let's deal with the mini mini Destiny anti- fan group first and
then I'll then I'll talk to you about Christian morality and
atonement. Sorry. Did Judge send it and receive nudes, which
is a federal crime? No idea. No idea. Positive influence on a
35-year-old man. Yes. If you don't like food chops, grow your
own G's. And now with teens on puberty blockers, they may never
fully mature and be vulnerable well beyond what's normal. I can
bet my life doctor is going to be also not offer destiny any
of the nuances that he offered him. Who's Nathan's mom? I don't
know. It's just pro destiny dick sucking. No, it's not. >> Decent
schizophrenic drama coverage. Sounds like we're giving a thumbs
up to your favorite mentally ill homeless person because they
made the most entertaining cardboard site. I mean, that's an
okay analogy. Shops looked at the camera and said they might
have said >> Oh, we've got so many more charts coming up,
guys.
sorry, I'm looking for thing. Everyone, check your phones right
now. Make sure hasn't sent you any tapes since the stream started.
These two were replies when people track back is hilarious. the
point which should not send and receive news from minor while
destiny did. Okay. Well, we addressed that earlier where we went
over we still morally condemned exactly what happened and we
also went over legalistic statutes. So go back. Um say when does
the demonic angle become too much to ignore. I don't think we're
ignoring it. We're talking about it talking about it or sorry
we're talking about it in very aggressive detail. Like like that's
the thing like you guys understand sweeping is hopping on the
stream ignoring the problem saying oh it's not that bad and then
talking about somebody else. But what we're doing instead is
we've broken down in detail the legalistic analysis. We've broken
it down in detail moral differences between the community I'm
trying to cultivate and the personal morality I hold and the
morality that Steven's community has uh cultivated and the morality
that he hold. >> Sorry, we got this sped way up right now
and we just got done documenting the exact age ranges and how
they should interact and treat each other. We've documented all
this stuff. Uh you said that broke the law talking about Destiny
doing it. Yeah, Ashley, I actually unironically covered that.
That was the beginning of the stream. That's the beginning of
the stream. Let me pull it up for you. And by the way, feel free
to share any counterpoints. uh Florida.
>> Uh I think the part you might not have been here, Sean,
but the the part that was worse to me, okay, was the very beginning.
He was going through the Florida statutes and he talks about
knowingly and he goes, "Stephven's told me and showed me DMs
where like this girl basically acknowledged she was 18 plus and
he had no reason to believe this. He had no reason to know. But
we all know, we've all seen the public DMs where Steven is told
that she's underage by Solo." I know I have DMs where I where
he acknowledges to me, Destiny acknowledges to me that Solo has
told him that she's underage, right? So, there's no way for him
to argue that he didn't have some indication she was underage.
There's just no way. He he can't he can't do it. It's out there.
And Connor not engaging with that to me shows exactly what he's
doing here. Yes, he is sweeping. He's going hard. >> State
statute uh child pornography distribution. So, what I said, I'll
summarize for you. Maybe uh maybe Stylo can come back and have
another non-argument.
Maybe he can just vaguely gau and try to say that there's hypocrisy
when there is none. >> Oh, please, for the love of God,
let Connor pull Stylo on. Oh my god, that would be I think I
would have heard about that if that actually happened. But I
would love if Connor pulled Stylo on. That would be hilarious.
>> We looked at these two or three statutes right here,
which are effectively secondderee felonies that carry a 15-year
penalty where if you produce or distribute child, then you're
guilty of a second degree felony that has a 15-year penalty.
And then possession says it is unlawful to knowingly possess
um control or intentionally view photograph motion picture exhibition
show representation image data computer detection or other presentation
which inhold a part he or she knows to include this stuff. So
I've already read the statute. So if Steven knew he's guilty
of a thirdderee felony and could be prosecuted for that as a
crime if he knew. His contention is that he didn't know and that
he has DMs that will do that. So do you have any objections to
my description of the legal issues?
For the love of God, could just somebody in the chat please just
say Solo told him November, I believe November 22nd, 23rd, 24th,
somewhere in there that she's underage. Please.
>> Well, Dub, it's right here. Kind of just broke it down
again. So, I mean, if you have a contention, watch it. And I
can pull up my drawing. >> Oh, we we did watch him like
speed read through uh section 4A, right? We I think we watched
him speed read through subsection 4. That clearly says it. Yes.
since you guys want my drawings. Doobie. Yeah, Doobie. Feel free
to articulate how uh you know I have no principles,
but you like me anyways, but you're sad that I have no principles.
Larry says, "Okay, I'm tired of Chud Dsing. Let's remember Chud
was having explicit comos with a 17-year-old. The paint he was
worried about the law." Sure. As I written to you in chat, absolution
calls for repentance. True. We'll get there in a sent. I really
haven't changed or more critically repent. He still owes the
public apology at the very least. Let's talk about that momentarily.
Why would you document that? I don't know what you're talking
about. Um use proper nouns. I mean, you already said Stephen
could be mass murder and you wouldn't be surprised. I don't know
why people think texting mine would be a dealbreaker. Well, right.
And he should still suffer the consequences. That's another thing
that I don't think people hear when I say it. >> So, we
get the only fans talking point again. The totally fake Only
fans talking point that Connor continues to run with. This is
this is exactly why we think you're sweeping Connor because every
time you talk about an Only Fans that doesn't exist and is easily
discoverable. Okay, everybody knows that. You talk to anybody
say, "Hey, did this [__] have an Only Vans?" You
talk to Destiny, he would tell you no. But you just keep letting
people repeat this. You don't You are unaware. You haven't watched
like some base level video on this topic. It's just bizarre.
It's bizarre.
What is that not coming through for you guys? Hold on. There's
no way my audio is not coming through. Oh, Ryland and Soapbox
can get timed out for like an hour, both of you. You're being
He thought somebody was an adult and that they were responsible
for figuring it out and making their own mistakes as a part of
growing up. That a 5year age gap is normal, but he might be socially
judged if he constantly dates 18 years old. Um, exclusive dating
18-year-olds could be predatory. that if he repeatedly d >> I
thought he was No, he just said he's just talked about how she
had an Only Fans. He's reading it and he's engaging with it.
He has no idea what the actual fact of the matter is. Being uninformed
on this and making definitive statements
how in the world can you tell me that I'm overegging the pudding
and you don't know basic facts of this,
right? He's saying, "Oh, Queen and Jay, they're just crazy Destiny
anti fans." It's like calling him for like any of this stuff.
That's that's totally ridiculous, right? But he does not a he
does not avail himself of the readily available facts.
Why? How can you call anybody else wrong or say anybody else
has has overexaggerated what's happened here when you don't know
the basic facts of the case? The basic facts of what's gone on
people. And Connor has no excuse because if Shawn, potentially
criminal, who was just on, if he can avail himself of the facts,
if he can go find the facts and he covers like a hundred different
topics, okay? He covers all kinds of topics and he can go look
this stuff up, then Connor's perfectly capable. Who just became
adults, he could be viewed as predatory. Uh I don't know if Desessie
knows this instinctively, but I think that if he doesn't know
it, he has autism, right? And then true love, meaning that if
you marry and have kids with somebody where you have a large
age gap, like let's say there's a 10ear age gap, 15 year age
gap. Let's say a 35-year-old man marries a 20-year-old woman.
I would be super judgmental of that. I would actually think that's
pretty up unless they genuinely love each other, stay together
forever, have kids, and have a healthy relationship. It's a red
flag to me, but I don't think that cops should show up and arrest
the couple, particularly if they're like a healthy, happy, welladjusted
couple, right? I I I don't think that's crazy. So, my beef is
I'm acknowledging what's going on. So So, okay. So, this is what
Stephen, according to him, this is the dynamic that he thought
he was interacting with, but he was interacting with this dynamic
by somebody who was 17. They're still immature. In my opinion,
they should be able to go on dates with parental supervision
and advice. They should be under Romeo and Juliet laws where
they can date adults or not adults. They can date people. Well,
thank God that Rose's parents were observing and did say no,
you can't go on this. No, you cannot. No, you cannot go to Miami.
Thank God for Rose's parents. Okay. >> Within a 2 to threeyear
age range, anybody who knowingly tries to pursue this group should
be viewed as potentially paraphilic or predatory. and that instead
of focusing on engaging in sex behavior, these people should
be academically and extracurricular focused to prepare for adulthood.
So, do um does anybody really have any objections with my characterization
of like Steven could be lying? Obviously, however, he's saying
that he's not guys um in terms of the time on the stream, we
got 38 minutes left. We are I believe oh, what is it? We are
about four subs. I think we're four subs away from another hour
on the stream. So, if you guys want to if you guys want to sub,
you want to donate. Okay, four subs away from another hour on
the stream. If you've enjoyed the content, go ahead. You'd sub
on kick, you can sub on Twitch, you can send me a Twitch primer,
you can go through Streamlabs or Kickbot to buy a TTS message.
All right. Uh, you can also go to the Patreon if you really really
want really want to help. But the Patreon does not contribute
to time on the stream. So, please do
donate to provide more time to the stream. Thank you guys very
much. >> Not and that he has evidence that he's not. Stephen
thought he was uh
I find that his actions in this category are objectionable, but
he was really interacting with this category and these are the
dynamics of this category. Does anybody have any objections with
what I said? Dubie says that looks correct in reference to the
Republican map, not in reference to the map I just showed. Conservative
liberalism says pivot reference was about you bringing up hypocrisy
and immediately pulled up Florida statutes. LOL. I don't know
if they have anything about being hypocritical degenerate. I
know you aren't doing it in bad faith. It's just hard to flush
out at a point. Sure. Maybe maybe we should talk about my ideal
uh momentarily. Um I don't know if I need a new drawing or my
dog is sitting on my
>> uh Soapbox Society. Thank you very much for the five
gifted. That's another hour on the stream. Let's go. Let's go.
Let's go. 1 hour 36 42. I knew there was a reason I didn't ban
you. >> I knew there was a reason. Thank you very much.
>> Counterpaints will be caught as >> That's why
That's why Soap That's why we love Soapbox. Okay. Not only does
she donate, not only does she uh contribute, she also apparently
can laugh at $250,000 a year as an annual salary. She's like,
"Oh, that's not that much. That's that's like that's not very
much money. Whatever you got going on, okay, I respect it." >> Most
popular channel. Maybe he's spending an absolute fortune. Absolutely.
He doesn't spend more, he cuts more funding. Uh yeah, he Yeah,
he's not only spending more. >> Soap box, you were never
timed out. >> He also cut taxes, which increases the deficit.
That's not fiscal conservative at all. So it it's actually like
anti that's not visible conservative at all. >> I need
to see there's an only fans comment that he's sniped sniped by.
I'm saying if she has an OF she's probably 19 like she said if
not we have a bunch of people who bought child bigger issue.
>> She doesn't hold on.
But we don't know who any of those people are. We have nobody
to track those people down. Why would we care about those people?
What? >> Oh it's actually like antithetical. How is Trump
sometimes anti-gay? Uh maybe Duby says, "Yeah, I get that Trump
is a bigger threat to the US and world over went to
>> Is Duby really going to argue
etc etc
in your opinion?" I would say that whatever civil statutes she
violated, let's say that Pixie, let's say that the Pixie lawsuit
goes forward in timewise,
um Pixie uh her leaks were uh within the time frame, let's say
that the judge and the jury think that uh Steven was reckless
with the way that he shared stuff and he was in violation of
the statute. She's entitled to $150,000 of liquidated damages.
Um and she might be entitled to lawyers fees. So if that happened,
I wouldn't oppose that outcome. I wouldn't be like, "Oh, Steven's
such a good guy." You know, the the the court found him incorrect.
No, he did something incorrect. And even if it's not a legal
issue, it's a moral issue, right? It seems extremely unlikely
he knew she was underage. Okay. The biggest new dumb [__]
development is >> Disco banned Dubbie from all his platforms.
Why? I actually have no idea why he banned Doobie. Seems kind
of crazy they banned Doobie to be honest with you. Posting her
pick in current college in DG chat after he'd already been talked
to lightly. Uh yeah, we should probably talk about morals
in a second. Uh Rose didn't have an Only Fans. Also put Solo
in prison. and source she had only I'm not looking up for Rose's
only fans. What the [__] Um source she didn't Well,
Rose didn't have an OF. She sold nudes on Twitter where there's
no age verification. >> Guys, are we Am I crazy or is uh
Russell logs no longer working? Russell search.dev no longer
working. Kind of crazy. Kind of seems a little crazy that Russell
search.dev is not working right now. Probably just an elastic
listenarch
is super hard to maintain. Okay, a growing elastic search cluster
that will constantly crash on you. So possibly they just have
to go and do it. Although I will say, no, I won't say. That guy
helped me out. Never mind. I won't say. Never mind. Asian. Okay,
that's horrific. The worst thing you could say about the age
thing up front is that it did seem suspicious in initial DMs,
but apparently didn't bother to fully confirm. He said, and by
the way, that's morally objectionable, reprehensible, criticizable,
he shouldn't do it in the future, etc., etc. That might feel
like a copout to you guys, but I mean the words that I just said
sincerely. Thomas says, "Depending on your age, 17 might even
be the legal age." Yep. Doobie says, "Not I totally agree with
your guard." Thank you. If Destiny doesn't provide any evidence
like he says he will, how will your thoughts change? Uh I don't
know if it's incumbent upon him to produce the DMs where they
discuss her age, unless she's going after him civily or criminally
or somebody else does like a civil suit with a freedom of information
request or something. I don't know. Dubie says, "I don't think
it makes sense to say he's a Peter right now. At worst, he was
suspicious uh too suspiciously too horny to verify before sending
her other people's nudes and shit." Yeah, all of this is criticizable.
too horny to verify before sending her other people's nudes and
yeah all of >> the doxing issue will nothing change is
criticizing Trump is obviously not your friend if you're LGBT
lol true doobie says oh god I unfortunately know who Bill Crystal
is sure wait for pound do dinos have stronger legs than frogs
no idea W dems but also lms true is a see now now like here guys
like right here so poor tour baller
I understand it dubbies engaging in good >> Connor goes
through all of these different chats that actually mean something
and he needs He needs to needs to zone in on Porter Beller saying
Desessie's
Now, this is the kind of thing that's really harmful to people,
okay? Calling this guy. This guy who like totally shares around
nudes without consent. This guy who records people without their
consent. This guy who
very much just doesn't care about the age of the young women
he's texting with. Okay,
it be the real harm isn't any of those things. The real harm
is you calling him a That's what's really bad here. Words on
the internet. Other people are engaging in good faith. I'm trying
to describe the situation as I see it as maximally as possible
and it seems like even super harsh critics are engaging with
what I'm actually saying. However, poor tour baller and similar
people to him will jump into uh Twitter mentions, replies, sometimes
DMs, not really DMs mostly. It's mostly just replies and they'll
be like, "He's a Destiny is a disavow him now." Actually, Doobie
says, "Frogs have the strongest legs." I know because I just
made it up. Unironically, frogs can jump super far. So, I would
not be >> Porter Beller won't be jumping into anybody's
messages, okay? Because unfortunately, Porter Beller has got
a weak timeout from Discord, I think. Sorry, from Twitter, I
think, for tweeting this image, which we now totally disavow,
by the way. We do not like this image. They totally disavow this
one. It's not funny at all. It's not funny at all. Okay. It's
not funny. It's not funny. It's not funny. >> Be surprised
if pound for pound they had stronger legs. Uh, does Rose not
have a father figure? I have no idea.
If if she does, I'm assuming she has a very poor relationship.
Um Jeffrey Hle and Destiny bought news from her on Twitter and
if he got age verification, it should be a super easy to dunk
on Arlers. Yeah, but he didn't get verification, right? Even
in the that have been leaked effectively, he says like, "Hey,
you're of age, right? Your profile was created a day ago." And
it seems like the response is you only have Destiny's side. You
don't have Rose's side. It seems like on his side, he's trying
to do age verification and make sure that she's not like a scammer
or whatever. Um, and she sends a picture allegedly with her face,
date, and name signed so she knew or so he knew it wasn't an
Indian guy trying to scam him for news.
Which is proof of what? In terms of her >> which by the
way, stupid, repulsive, criticizable, disgusting. Don't do it.
Right. But what is the correlated appropriate response? What
is the correlated appropriate punishment? Valor made the uh the
chart the uh the thumbnail. That's pretty funny. I keep seeing
people claim they saw something that said she was yet not proof
is shown. Uh I went to the Kiwi Farms thread. On the Kiwi Farms
thread, they have a young lady who goes by a certain name who
got a speeding ticket who was born in October of 2004. Whether
or not that's true, I don't know. Uh the internet is a wild place.
It's impossible to know the true identity of people you're talking
to. If someone lies about their age, there really is no way to
prevent that. Or just like don't super young people. There are
ways to prevent that. And by the way, when you take those reasonable
precautions to make sure that the person's of age, it turns out
law enforcement, a bunch of other people will be way more understanding,
right? Way more understanding when you take those reasonable
precautions.
>> I mean, that that's another option. Dubbie says, "Maybe
I'm just got more hope that there are still enough sane conservatives
in the US to drag the party away from MAGA than you do. If that's
how you feel, I retract Hunter has no principles." Well, thank
you. I appreciate that. Um, and by the way, Dubbie, I'm happy
to work with Bull Work. I'm happy to work with um >> Thank
you. >> Uh Bullwork. I'm happy to work with Bill Crystal.
I'm happy to work with effectively like any centerright dude.
Um any center right dude I would be happy to work with. Uh Dubie
says, "I encourage you to keep your head in hopes high." No,
no. Trump Trump's going to die and Maga is going to fracture.
There's already signs. I'm with you. Fazer says she does absolutely
believe that based on everything she said out of all stages of
litigation, the issue is that it doesn't hold weight. Okay. Uh
we've moved into politics. I don't know if you guys noticed,
but this is a drama stream. This isn't supposed to be a politics
stream. My wife and I had first a couple months ago party is
the current gener. I think a lot of Christian will excuse and
why it's the fasting bargain happen. That's not how we will talk
about that. I'll draw
>> the part where he actually
yeah perspective and I want to get into debate shows and I want
to do panels and I want to discuss more than whatever usually
chat is with you not having more smoke for testing but you have
a similar level of smoke for people who dislike him more than
you J Queen whatever rubs me wrong. That's fair. Okay, that's
fair. But can I can I just be real about something? Like like
can we all be real? Whenever whenever one of our people that
we parasially dislike or like
what? How is it parasocial? This guy came on my stream multiple
times. This guy actually talked to me in DMs. How is it parasocial?
How is that not just social? Where is the parasocial element?
Parasocial means one-sided. It was parasocial
100%.
Stop being parasocial. We started engaging together, right? Like
like both being streamers. That's not streamer friendships are
not parasocial. You do content with people, you do collaborations
with them fairly consistently. That's not parasocial. >> We
use
almost as a subconscious default either hyperbolic or aggressive
language with people we don't like. And we use minimizing language
with people we like. Okay, let's just bring up Brianna Woo. Okay,
so as an example, Brianna Woo has done nothing mean to me. >> Brianna
Woo. Connor refers to Brianna Woo as a human being. And this
is how we know that he is sweeping for her. This is how we know
he loves her. Okay, cuz it's totally minimizing. It's totally
disingenuous to pretend Brianna Woo is just a normal human being.
Okay, very disgusting behavior from Connor. >> She's been
she's been nice. She's facilitated other conversations with other
uh politically connected people that have led to really good
connections
that allowed me to have really cool conversations with really
cool smart people. And so, Briana has never wronged me. Uh translation
B not criticizing Briana leads to money for me. So Woo.
That's a great position to have, Connor. What a cool position.
>> That being said, Briana took a healthy chunk of criticism
from Queenman. Took a large large large amount of
>> Did she or did she just totally like mute him every
time he got rolling on any point? >> Criticism from the
commentary space. took a buttload of stuff for her involvement
with PV and effectively has gone into her own little creative
hug box. Now, if you bring up those criticisms of Briana, I'm
going to say like, "Hey, these criticisms exist, but I'm obviously
going to use sanitized language because I like Briana." And if
there's somebody who was like very cruel,
um like Quean, I like Queman, by the way. Um, I just think he's
kind of like an cruise missile similar to President Sunday. Then
I'm going to bring up Hyperbolic. >> Oh, this is actually
a good point that I keep forgetting to bring up, guys. Um, Cherry
reminds me of this point uh sometimes. Uh, if you bought merch,
if you buy merch, shouldn't you know the person's address and
stuff? What the [__] Right? Shouldn't you know
Shouldn't you know that person's address if they bought merch
or if you sent them merch? Why Why was there no way for this
guy to track that person down? Can anyone explain that? olic
language, but truth be told, that's also good for the goose,
good for the gander. Queen uses hyperbolic language about everybody
he hates all the time. So that's where you can say that I'm subconsciously
rhetorically sweeping for people I like and I'm being hyperbolic
and abrasive about people that I don't like. Number one, I think
that's just human and subconscious.
Um, number two, I think that some of the parties that you're
talking about, they're infinitely more aggressive than I am.
>> That's probably true. More aggressive than Connor is.
Connor Connor does downplay things a lot of all over the >> Green
Jedi says, "Can I ask a good faith question? If someone goes
into adult space like a 21 plus club with a fake ID, should a
man that sleeps with her should be charged as a Nope." The answer
is no. Fatimo. >> That I just wish they could stop lying.
Could they just stop lying about what's actually happening here?
That's not what >> Says, "Uh, Nala was lioness from Lion
King." Nice. It feels like saying what Destiny did is a similar
level of bad for being really mean to him. I mean, you can read
that subconsciously, but I don't know if that's true. I do think
being mean on the internet is not as bad as sexing 17-year-olds.
Somehow, I just feel like he says it and I feel like that was
actually painful for him to admit, but he doesn't show in his
face. It's like the do meme. Okay, I can tell he got hurt. He
hurt himself saying that, but I can't prove it. Okay, I can see
it. I can see it, but I can't prove
Deas Houseion posted this very edgy thing that I'm not going
to read out loud. That is bananas.
Uh, Doobie says she made her Twitter account on 41 and by 44
she was sending her other people uh videos and stuff, but she
listed herself as 18 in the Twitter bio. Sure. Hey,
did I miss the part where he saw about me saying yes, you did
miss it Porter Beller, you did miss it. He was mad. You called
Desi. Let's [__] up. Sure. Only one who watches ends
up in Jtocks and Queenman's video as a donator. True. True. Well,
Dubby's got cash, so you know, feel free to make it rain. >> Never
mind. Don't Doobie. Doobie, come talk about politics over here.
Doobie. Doobie. Hello, Doobie. We need money. Doobie, throw us
some money. Doobie.
>> Yo says, "That's very real and recognizing human behavior
and bias. Thanks for being open." Connor, dude, I I can only
tell the truth. That That's the only thing that I can do. Okay.
Um, Dubie says you should dislike Brianna Woo because I dislike
Brianna Woo, not because she hasn't been mean to you.
Sure. And by the way, I do think the Zio propaganda has gone
way too far. Um, but yeah, even if I criticize Zo propaganda
between Pisco and I, but uh
I mean them rub me wrong because >> Sorry, I'm just I'm
looking for interesting chat messages, I guess. Hussein says,
"Jay Stock and Queman and people like them rub me wrong because
they basically just profit off a drama farming and that behavior
is sew the wind, reap the whirlwind." I mean, I agree, but I
also think that Steven is uh sewing. >> Sorry, I have to
go burn the bridge with Doobie right now. Give me a second. >> Uh,
he's reaping. He's reaping right now. Doobie says, "Wait, I don't
even watch JTock. Laugh my ass off. That dude has a whiny, nerdy
voice. Can't watch his streams." Rude. Very rude. >> I
could just be like every other boring streamer who talks down
in this register all the time. You know what? I'm going to do
that for the rest of the stream. We're going to talk >> Dreamcast
says, "I don't know if you answered me previously." >> It's
the gayest. It's a total lack of confidence in who you are as
a person, but we'll do it anyway because other people perceive
that as being more authoritative. If you need somebody's voice
to sound like this to trust them or to think they're authoritative,
you have no internal monologue. You are a bot who is being convinced
by people who just sound good and not the actual things they're
saying. So, probably, you know, think about ways to get and access
Canadian healthcare. But in the meantime, listen to me now. >> See
Media Network. I was offline. I wouldn't want to unvoluntarily
spam questions. Uh, no. Uh, ask the question again. If I answered
you, I don't remember answering you. I thought he was going to
say dogs. I do love dogs, but I have dogs. Nope. We'll uh we'll
talk down in this register for the rest of the stream because
this is what people say they want. And I I really think it's
weird. Personally, I just think it's disturbing that you can't
listen to the things somebody says. You got to listen to the
tone of their voice to decide whether or not they're authoritative.
It's kind of embarrassing for you. And I don't really love participating
in it, but if I have to, I will.
Because I can't have a bear, right? Yeah.
Goats are cool. Goats indeed are cool. All right. Listen, guys.
I I get it that it's a We're going to do another drawing real
quick. Uh we're we're going to talk about like the clout dynamic.
Uh different community dynam dynamics. We're going to talk about
all that. >> Um so I will be busting out Microsoft Paint
again. Some of you probably just feel gross.
>> Probably start drinking myself relationship thing. Can
I get your >> back to our charts
streaming like I am now? >> Oh, right. We've got the friendship
chart. Let's go. >> Community crosspollination. >> Let's
go. >> Right. So, the more that you interact with a creator,
that's good. Then the more that you're going to get crosspollination.
So people who might not have watched Destiny, they might crosspollinate
into Destiny, but I have way less
to offer him than he has to that wait, I have way less to offer
him than he has to offer me, right? Because every time that I've
gone on Destiny, like uh I I went on
Let me back up a little bit. I've debated Destiny before. I've
fought Destiny before, but when you're only streaming, you know,
5 hours a week, I'm not going to lie, there it's just very hard
to grow. I was effectively hard stuck between 50 and 100 depending
on topic, >> only streaming 5 hours a week >> because
I could only stream 5 hours a >> right? Because I was working
a 40hour week job. I had, you know, I had to take care of my
wife. I had to take care of my kids. I had to take care of my
>> I had social responsibilities.
I had um I I had my side hustle with the Warhammer stuff, so
I really only could stream like once or twice a week. So, I was
maximally streaming 5 to 10 hours a week. It's super hard to
grow. But when you're streaming like I am now, 25 hours a week,
so I'm live Monday through Friday, 9:30 a.m. to 2:30 p.m., it's
easier to grow. Right
now, the problem is obviously every interaction I have with advantageous
to me >> because I'll get another half dozen to a dozen
um additional people who will watch the stream just because they're
like, "Oh, you know what? Conor's kind of weird. He said this
crazy thing. I thought that was entertaining. I thought it was
funny." And so as a result, they come over to the stream or they
say, "Oh, actually genuinely I align with Conor more than I was
Stephen and I'm going to come over to Conor stream." And that's
happened, bro. Like we we started this stream on Counterpoint
like 50 viewers. We're up to generally speaking 150 to 200. And
then also same thing with Valerie Reacts. Valerie Reacts. I've
crossed my audience between counterpoints politics and Valerie
Reacts and we got Valer Reacts or excuse me, Valor up to the
same, right? Um, so as a result, I've tripled my stream audience
by starting this. >> But the problem with this dynamic
is that Destiny can never fully can never fully trust me because
let's say that I'm evil. Okay, let's say that I'm an evil piece
of and I would argue that like Vos and Hassan have already done
this. I would argue that um some other creators have done this
um even smaller creators who actually didn't end up being able
to capitalize on it, but the the backstab >> the backstab
>> the backstab clout incentive
this just perpetually exists. Okay. And so let's say that there's
something that Stephen, right? Let's say for instance in 2022
he DM'd a girl who was 17, right? Uh let's just use the backstab
incentive as like 500, right? If I who am friendly to Stephen
and friendly to Steven's community, if I backstab right now and
like not that I have something to backstab him with, everything
we're talking about is in the open, right? But there's a backstab
cloud incentive where not only will I get my regular audience
who watches my content, but there will be people from Steven's
audience who will come and check out the backstab.
And if they agree with me, they might come over.
hold shift control-l. What does shift do? >> They just
want straight lines. >> Okay, that's cool. Learn something
new every day. They might agree with me and they might come over
uh to my uh stream and they'll check out the backstab stream,
but then the question is whether or not you can retain those
people, right? And so, in my opinion,
uh Vosch was able to do the backstab clout and succeed. Hassan
was able to do the backstab clout. Uh Max Carson was able to
do so. And so there's always this thing in the background where
Steven can never really trust me. But the question is whether
or not you're truly Steven's friend. >> Hold on. I don't
know why you'd throw those all into the same bucket. It seems
pretty obvious to me that Max found some actual malfeasants on
Destiny's part. Had actual real criticisms, actual real problems,
and he just stuck to his morals. I don't know why it's the backstab
clout incentive. I think it's pretty obvious to say that Max
could have just looked the other way and had way more incentive.
There's way more incentive to not backstab in that scenario.
Can we talk about that? The incentive to suck this guy's. Can
we add the the third option here, which is the sorry, the second
option, which is the sucking clout incentive for Connor. And
that that incentive becomes even larger as the malfeasants on
Destiny's part grows. Okay, Connor has the biggest sucking incentive
imaginable. The the the incentive to suck for Destiny is higher
than it's ever been for Connor right now. Okay, and he is he
is taking full advantage. Okay, it's way bigger than the backstab
clout incentive right now. Everybody who's still in Desty's community
are the biggest cult members. There is no backstab incentive
right now. There is nothing but incentive. Okay. And Connor is
taking full advantage,
right? That that is like another thing is that when you're peer
creators, you can be pure creators or you can be friends. And
the truth is that like I've hung out with Stephen enough that
I hope well okay front okay front however you want to describe
it. there was a falling out and they were able to lolly they
were able to leverage the disagreement in order to rip out chunks
of Steven's audience. Right? So anyways, the point is from my
perspective is Steven ultimately is a human being. I'll be real
there's a whole bunch of people who just disconnect,
right? Who just disconnect from Destiny because they don't like
Destiny and and to be like, "Oh well, they ripped that chunk
out of Steven's audience." It's like, no, I don't know about
Vos and Hassan because I don't remember the particulars of how
those situations went down. But for Max, I think a lot of people
were just like, "Oh, Desessie's really disgusting. they left,
right? With me, I think that's more of what it is. Desty's just
really disgusting they've left. I happen to be a creator. They
watched, but I think a lot of people weren't necessarily going
to stick with me as a creator, right? I And I think that's totally
fair. That's fine. I don't I don't begrudge those people, but
it's not like I ripped those people out of Destiny's community.
Destiny exiled those people from his community through his actions.
The way of looking at it is like, oh, these people who call Destiny
out for the wrongdoing, they're like tearing audience away. That's
not really what it is, right? That's not what it is at all.
So, if I'm a friend,
>> there's this dynamic where you never want to like totally
criticize Destiny because you don't want to lose the clout relationship,
but at the same time, you also don't want to get steamrolled
and totally lose your moral compass either. And so, what I'm
trying to do is I'm trying to do the friend bridge. And I'm just
trying to and I think Aerodite does too, by the way. Let's call
it the the bridge of friendship. And the bridge of friendship
can only m be maintained
if you're not a sickopantic dick sucker, but you're also not
a enemy. That's like and so as a result, >> what separates
Connor from a sickopantic dick sucker? Can I can I get what public
action has Connor taken that separates him from any other sickopantic
dick sucker? And who is a sickopantic dick sucker you can compare
him to? Cuz I don't see any difference. I don't see anything
Connor's done that actually chastises Destiny in any meaningful
way. >> Oh, that's kind of where you have to make the choice.
Do you backstab for Clout? Do you try to remain a friend? Or
do you separate from the orbit entirely? So, so that that's kind
of where for me, um, at least so far, I'm trying to maintain
the bridge of friendship because I think a lot of people have
fallen prey to the backstab clout incentive or front stab cloud
uh or the front stab clout incentive. Um, but if you want to
maintain that thing, then you just have to treat him like another
friend. You effectively have to ignore the you can you can criticize
the you can truthfully,
but you would treat it as if your friend as if you had like a
degen freak friend who did something who did something crazy
three years ago. I don't know um if this makes sense. Uh, I hope
it makes sense to some degree and uh, I hope you guys kind of
understand >> you don't see a difference between Food Chops
and Connor. No, I don't see a large difference between Food Chops
and Connor. I think Food Chops and Connor are basically like
a very similar person. Like I I actually don't because you have
to think about if if Connor just says what Destiny did there
is bad, is Destiny actually upset by that? In terms of are they
going to step on Destiny's toes in any substantial way? They
are the precise same person. That's it. uh what I'm going for
and that I would say this is probably the most amount of criticism
that I've received is I'm treating this like a bridge of genuine
friendship instead of like the peer-to-peer clout dynamic. And
so people are like why are you tolerating all this bad behavior?
Why don't Yeah, I'd say this is more what it is, Don Devil. Like
food shops is at least not in denial about what she is, right?
And she's taking full advantage of that in a way Connor can't.
Connor is in total denial about who and what he is. That's the
issue for him, right? He doesn't admit what he is. He he doesn't
look at his principles that he puts by he he lets go. He lets
just flow off by the wayside, right? He just lets them go. He
just lets them go like he's curling and he's in that last minute.
He's just like lets his hand go and he just realize his principles
slide away like the rock. Okay, like the rock and curling. He's
not aware of that happening. He doesn't see it. He thinks he's
still got his principles with him. They've they've left long
ago. >> Don't you front. Why don't you backstab him? It's
because number one, I don't want to fall prey to this behavior.
Uh, number two. I'm hoping Stephen
>> based on what? This is like watching an alcoholic who
you will not intervene with at all. Okay. Like a crackhead, actually.
Like a a addict. And you're like, I really just hope they improve.
I just got my fingers crossed that they'll improve. Uh, no. They
can't help themselves anymore, right? You would have to step
in. If you were actually a friend, you would be stepping in.
Stop calling it the bridge of actual friendship. I'm treating
this like an actual friendship. Then you're a friend. This guy's
actually destroying everything he's built. He's been destroying
it for months and you don't step in and say,
>> Why are you pretending you're a friend? You're [__]
>> So, actually, a lot of people are saying like, "Okay,
but Steven so bad. These are the kind of friends that I don't
keep around." That's actually interesting. Uh, I'm going to do
uh >> No, when you're a close friend and they [__]
up, you can stick with them, but you have to make sure they're
fixing their [__] If you just sit there and you go,
"Well, I really hope they fix that someday. I'm just going to
I'm just going to refuse to acknowledge I'm just going to refuse
to ever take into account what they've done wrong and try to
stop them from harming people further. I'm just going to totally
issue that and you know I'm just going to cross my fingers and
hope they change. That's not friendship. That's not real
>> Plout bridge uh friendship.
>> Yes. Private huff. Yes, exactly. My friend wants to
drive drunk. I'm just going to pray for them. I'm going to pray
for them. I'm going to keep inviting them over to uh to poker
night where they get drunk and I'm going to pray for them. I'm
going to hand them the keys after they've had a couple beers
and I'm going to pray for them. I'm going to hope they change
next week. I hope you don't do that. Hey. Hey, Connor. Connor,
can I get my keys? I I know I had a couple beers, but can I get
my keys? Here's here you go, Stephen. I just want you to know,
Stephen, this is bad, but here are your keys. When you come back
next week, I'll hand these keys to you, but I'm going to let
you know again that this is really bad. You shouldn't be doing
it. And he's like, "Whatever you say, Connor. I'm going to go
drive drunk now. Bye." Fantastic >> And then let's do a
new one. >> Great friend. >> With a new one, there's
this Christian conception.
And you have to understand like um sin. Let's make it bigger.
72.
Sin. Caps lock. Sin. Um
what is it? Like guilt. I got
guilt. Mercy. >> Really? Oh, here he's going to perfectly
describe the the process of forgiveness. Okay. And I believe
based on his next stream, because we looked at it a little bit,
I believe he's going to identify that Destiny does not go through
these things and there's like no process towards forgiveness.
But that won't mean anything, will it? He's just gonna hope the
destiny changes. >> Atonement. Sorry if it's a little bit
of dead air while I'm drawing this, but it's kind of important.
>> Forgiveness. And this is this is a um this is a a Christian
conception. Okay. So, so I understand you're going to be like,
"Oh, there was some Buddhist temple 3,000 years before Christ."
I also believe this. I don't give a [__] Okay. I
don't give a [__] that Asians came up with it first.
[__] the Asians. Okay. That's obviously a hyperbolic
joke. I'm being racist. Um let me delete that one. Let me do
this one. Let me do this. And let me do that.
Okay. So, the whole reason why I'm drawing this is because I
actually have problems with my chat right now. >> And the
reason why I have problems with my chat is because while I don't
literally believe in God, I think that this dynamic is the best
dynamic for human beings to interact. I really do. It goes into
Christian turning the other cheek. It goes into like the the
golden rule. It goes into like Christian philosophy about like
the redemption of souls. Um, this is all, you know, it's all
tied into like Christian religiosity. What you don't >> Yeah.
I I didn't know that. I didn't know that he doesn't literally
believe in God. That seems odd. >> Won't have to take literally.
Okay. >> I don't know why you introduce yourself as a Christian
when you don't believe in God. Isn't there there must be some
name for like being an observational Christian who doesn't believe
in the actual religion. Right. >> But for me, sin is real.
Okay.
>> Yeah. I I don't think it's appropriate to call yourself
a Christian if you don't believe in God. Right. I I don't think
it's appropriate to call yourself a Christian just as a as a
standalone term. Yeah. It it feels very strange to say I'm a
Christian, but then you don't believe in God. Sin is antisocial
behavior that results that correlates it doesn't cause it correlates
with consequences. Right? So if you're a freak, you're going
to be you're going to be a hedonistic monster that eventually
is going to burn out on normal and drug- based pleasures like
weed, alcohol, and monogous sex with a single partner. And you're
going to keep looking for uh more and more extreme behaviors.
And so as a result of not even believing that these behaviors
are bad, you're going to continue engaging bad behaviors and
eventually you're going to suffer consequences. And I think that
religious people who meditated, did drugs, did mushrooms, they
realized that sin correlates with consequences, right? And then
guilt is typically when you realize that it's typically that
you realize that your behavior was antisocial, it was cringe,
it was bad, you hurt other people, you hurt yourself, etc., etc.
Then when it comes to mercy, mercy is actually not um for the
sinner to decide. It's more for society or God to decide. And
so what Christianity kind of says is that once a person um seeks
mercy because they know that they've committed sin, they are
guilty about it and they're begging for mercy from the people
for whom they've wronged, then they can atone for their sins,
right? And so atonement is where you realize that you have bad
behavior. It's like go forth and sin no longer, right? I think
that's a direct biblical quote. Go forth and sin no longer. Not
only do you try to fix your fix your mistakes as much as you
can, right? you you can't fix the mistakes necessarily, but you
can try and you can try to make it right to the people that you've
wronged and then eventually if somebody
>> it's like they're begging Destiny to do a fake apology
so it's easier for them to defend him. Oh, I mean they would
have absolutely wanted Destiny to do a fake apology, right? Ardite
literally laid out the reasons why he should unblock Pixie and
talk to her and try to convince her to like not go nuclear,
right? Do you remember Ardite doing the pros and cons of being
a human being around Pixie?
She sent the damn to Destiny saying like, "Here's why you here's
why you should unblock her and talk to her like a person and
here's why if you don't unblock her, what could happen? She goes
nuclear and and your whole [__] blows up, right?"
I don't think that's because she thinks Destiny feels genuine
remorse.
That is because she's trying to tell him how to actually act
like a human being. Engages in sin, they feel guilt. They seek
mercy. They atone for their sins. Then they should have some
degree of forgiveness. Now my problem with this whole let's call
it like a slide is that BGG in my opinion and Steven to a degree
I don't even think they believe in sin right this kind of goes
back to the the moral analysis of communities where we had uh
let me pull up COG DG moral differences so for me I'm an absurdist
I don't literally believe in the Bible um I do believe in burking
institutions deferring to social institutions I am a social conservative
I'm a mild fiscal conservative I'm anti-genery anti conservative
or at least wrote that
the con which
eliminate consequences.
If you eliminate the consequence every time Connor talks about
his principles, you can literally skip that entire section.
He it doesn't matter. You don't have to take anything he says
seriously about his principles. He doesn't believe in them. Okay?
They don't matter. You just skip that entire thing. It's a complete
waste of time. You just skip forward and see what he's going
to say after this and see if it's remotely consistent, okay?
with anything he said before. But when he actually lays out his
principles, that is like the least useful information that exists
on the internet, right?
By far. Send me a 1995 Geio Cities website and I'll read that
on like Dragon Ball Z or some. I'm getting the year way too early.
Like 2005 Geio's website on Dragon Ball Z. There's going to be
way more useful information there than any list of counterpoints
as principles.
>> Then you can endlessly engage in sin, right? Like if
you don't get herpes, if you don't get AIDS, if you don't get
somebody pregnant, and also if you have shallow emotional relationships
where the other person doesn't get that hurt and you don't get
hurt, well then guess what? You can endlessly engage in sin and
suffer no consequences with this moral outlook. >> Except
do you believe that actually happens, Connor, or do you believe
like
do you believe that only aberant people can engage in that and
that most people will actually be hurt by that in the long run?
I know Connor believes that most people will be hurt in the long
run cuz he said as much before >> and so I think it's still
open so I'll open up a second one. But I view that as immature
hedenism. And this is where I think that doing hard drugs, you're
always going to pay a price. Being generous, you're always going
to pay a price. Being is good. But being aophilic negative, but
making excuses for aphibophilia, I think you're going to [__]
hurt yourself in the long run. Lollcon negative/neutral, I think
that's going to hurt you in the long run. I think tying your
beliefs in like sin or consequences or bad behavior to consequentialism
is stupid and it gives you moral license to do really bad. And
I think that you get trapped on the hadonic treadmill and that
being pessimistic about ideals and virtues and believe that believing
that everyone ultimately sucks and should stop living in that
denial of virtue and vice um I think you're going to [__]
yourself. And I think wisdom is revealed by her children and
her fruits. So for me um I'm just trying to convince Steven that
sin or like a modern interpretation of sin even exists. I'm just
trying to convince Steven that he should even follow the guilt,
mercy, atonement, forgiveness pipeline. I'm trying to convince
DGG that this concept exists and they should pay they should
pay attention to it because even if you don't believe in it literally,
it can still massively help you in life. So, um, so yeah. Um,
I could talk about projected ideal stuff, but we're kind of running
out of time. Oh, no, we got 10 minutes. We got 10 minutes. I
can say this. I can say this and I can show you one more and
then I'll engage with chat a little bit before we move into Valerie
Reacts. Um, the Mercy. So, he just drew this whole thing to go
Yeah. And Destiny like can engage in this. Just drove this. He
drew this and was like, here's how it works. Here's how society
would work well. Yeah. Desi doesn't do any of this. Oh, okay.
>> Excuse me. The forgiveness
cycle. Um, yeah. Then let's see what >> does Connor not
know what enabling behavior is. He's never shown a willingness
to push back on anything. I think probably somewhere in like
private. He goes, "Destiny, you know what you're doing is like
bad, right?" And Destiny goes, "Yeah, [__] those
people though." And Connor's like, "Well, I tried. I did my best,
guys. I said it was Destiny when you raided that lollycon and
small pee food shops while she was reacting to your minor son's
content. You gave her permission to react to your minor son's
content. I thought that was weird and bad. And Desty's like Connor,
nobody cares about what you say. And Connor's like, "Well, I
tried. I tried, guys. Well, I don't know what to do beyond that.
I just tried my best. I tried my best." Uh, okay. Um, yeah. Your
best was dog. Your best was garbage.
new. Okay. So, let's say that we had uh Twitch and YouTube politics.
Let's say that we had three large streamers, Hassan,
Vos,
Destiny, and then you had everybody else. Okay? And then you
had real world politics or what we could do with real politics.
So,
um let's just call this Twitch and
>> Uh Twitch, >> what is the purpose of this? Let's
reduce the size 22. This will probably be my last draw before
we start wrapping it up and going into uh Twitch polics. Okay,
then let's put on here.
And then let's say like I'm over here. I'm like microscopic.
>> It's like dude, you don't need to disavow your friends,
but you do need to push them to get help. You do need to push
them to stop hurting people, right? If your friends are engaging
in really really really behavior that's hurting people and you
don't try to help them or try to get them fixed in any way. If
you if you don't make actual if I mean beyond just like hey you
know that's bad right? You know that's bad right? I mean like
hey unless you're going to make some changes I'm not going to
be here anymore. You value this friendship at all? No I'm not
going to be here anymore. Here's what you can do to have me as
a friend. If you're not willing to do any of these things I'll
help you with them. I'll take you to your meetings. I'll make
sure you make I'll I'll keep your schedule for you. I will make
sure you get there, right? I'll help you get up in the morning.
We can go like for a walk and talk about how these things are
affecting you. We can do so many things. I'm willing to give
you so much time. We could be actual friends. But if you're not
willing to fix anything, I can't be around you. That's what real
friends do, right? That's what real friends do. Conor's not operating
on that level.
>> Let's put me right here >> because Destiny does
not feel like Connor's a real friend, right? Destiny is not going
to accept any of those things from Connor at all. Okay, I'm so
small that my my text won't even fit. So, I'm I'm going to draw
with a pencil. CG or C OG, right? C OG. Okay, horribly drawn,
but who gives a [__] Then, let's say over here, uh,
we have what's possible for Twitch and YouTube politics to be.
Um, so let's say we do, uh, camping events. Let's say we do disaster
relief. Disaster relief. Uh, let's say we do IRL community events.
Let's say we do IRL community building. These are the things
that we can sell to the mainstream media and to the mainstream
political atmosphere and say that we have um disunity
civilian um I guess phone banking I think that's okay phone banking
you get the idea these are the things that affect real world
politics uh real worldworld
politics okay and right now we're having this problem at least
I think it's a problem where Hassan has millions of dollars and
he hoards it for himself like a dragon okay so Hassan is going to
hoard all his cash and not only that he's kind of apologizing
piece of [__] and so I never really want to work
with him. Vosch is a little bit less bad because he's like a
anarchist libertarian whatever he doesn't believe in an overthrown
constitution of the United States. I don't think he's incrementalist
and so maybe we could work with Vos and let's just go ahead and
take this slice of the pio's community as far as this is like
time, money, energy, attention, right? That this is what these
things are representative of. Then let's say that uh we're friends
with Destiny and we have some influence and we can convince Destiny
and Vos that it is worthwhile to take the millions of dollars,
the passion that's in their communities, the the clout and influence
that they have as creators and to chip off 5 to 10% of their
energy and to put it into canvasing events, disaster relief,
IRL community events, IRL community building and phone banking.
Now, >> okay, this is all fine. Unfortunately, the two
people you're willing to engage with have like credible accusations
that they feel attractions
attraction to drawn or real depictions of minors. They feel that
this attraction, right? They they can now be tied to that credibly.
It's the exact reason that like a mainstream political candidate
for the Republicans would probably not want Adam Gates around.
Matt Gates. Matt Gates, not Adam Gates. Matt Gates. Right now,
I understand that Matt Gates was around Trump and that was fine.
Trump is very different. Okay. Trump has. Imagine DG was a thousand
times bigger than it is, but just as cultlike. That's what Trump
has going on. Okay? Nobody else has that. Do not try to play
by Trump's rules. You will lose. You don't get to play by Trump's
rules. You don't have a cult that size. Okay? But otherwise,
for the rest of the world, okay? These two people can be political
poison. They're very entertaining. They have very big audiences
if you work with them directly, which is the entire purpose of
PV, by the way. these names were too toxic to attach to candidates.
Right? Hassan for all his warts, for all his problems, he is
not too toxic to talk to candidates. He has not had any interactions
with minors. Right? He has not tried to groom minor. He's not
talked about having sex with minors later. He's not talked about
flying minors out. Right? Hassan's never done this. Bosch and
Destiny, yes. Va Hassan, no. Sorry, no credible ones, dude. Sure.
There's the Paris Jackson thing. So unfortunately if if you think
of politics as a zero- sum game all I have to do when destiny
is a part of canvasing for my opponent as I say my opponent has
a canvasing for them credibly accused actual evidence self-admitted
holding cam holding child look it's the guy who who hoards child
it's the guy who confessed to some random YouTuber that he had
a big stash of child on his computer and it's over right there
all of this all of this piece you just
Go [__] yourself. It's over. It's destroyed. It's
gone. It's set on fire. It's ashes. There's nothing left. >> Now,
maybe we're not going to get that much. Maybe in the Twitch to
play Spear out of all the money and all the time and all the
attention spent in this sphere, we might get 1% or 2% or 5% or
10%. But this to me is infinitely more important than all this
online. And so what I want to do is I want to build uh realistically
a community that is no longer that small where I can take all
my time, energy, and attention and I can take at least 10% of
the money and pour it into these things. So anyways, that kind
of sucks though when Vos sucks and looks at Sorry, I don't want
that one. I want this one. When Vosch looks at Lon and becomes
politically unpalatable and also talks about all sorts of [__]
fortress arc and then Destiny does all the crazy stuff he does
that obviously destroys all of this. So yeah. So if I constantly
make pragmatic appeals to Destiny, please stop doing all this
crazy fit because you're for all these things. It's because this
is kind of my mission. This is the things that I think actually
matter. I think we like stream fun. I love having a digital community.
I love talking to you guys about stuff. I hope that I've given
you some things to think about today. Um, however, like if we
could do canvasing for political people that actually matter,
that are actually decent human beings, if we could do disaster
relief for our fellow Americans, if we could do IRL community
events where we actually meet up and build a sense of community,
um, if we do phone banking for political movements that actually
matter, that's infinitely more important than this, right? So,
so I'm going to say that and obviously um, sexing a 17-year-old
is counterproductive to this effort. Counter uh, Twitch poll
energy. All right, something chat before we move into uh, move
into the next segment, which will be a valid reactant. I need
to send Dan Pace and invite. So, let me go ahead and invite guests.
Although, I'm going to hold off for a minute. Um, and I'm just
going to text Ann. Um, yeah, give me a second. I'm finishing
up the drama.
Um, anyways, but ask ask whatever questions, concerns, or comments.
I'm going to scroll a couple pages and see how you guys like
my forgiveness gra.
Um, Matthew want to see if
uh I mean, unfortunately, Stia, nobody cares about the people
Destiny hurts. I do. Some people do, but like nobody in the mainstream
in mainstream politics cares about that, right? It is about pol.
It is about optics. If you're trying to convince Connor why this
is bad, right? You use different arguments. Connor is never going
to care that Destiny hurts people. He doesn't give a he does
not care. He does not give a single [__] right? He
never will give a [__] Uh to be honest, before I
had personal relationships with these people, I did not really
give a [__] Right? So, you have to give him different
arguments. And unfortunately for him, he's making it's way easier
to make the Destiny is optics poison argument than anything else.
Right? Like it's difficult to argue why people should care about
Destiny hurting people. Um it requires people on the internet
to have a conscience and care about the people they view as entertainment,
which is just never going to happen, right? If you've learned
anything from this stream when we cover like Darius and and the
IRL streamers, all of this other stuff, people don't view these
people with any conscience. They they're just monkeys for them
to dance, right? Lots of the people who view stuff in this in
this space are like socially maladjusted, terrible human beings.
Lots of people in my audience, socially maladjusted, terrible
human beings. Now, I appreciate the views you guys give me. Um,
but you are horrible people. A lot of you are
I appreciate the views. I appreciate the donations, but there
are a lot of horrible people here. That's just true. Uh, that
gets revealed every time I
That gets revealed a lot. Okay. There are a lot of horrible people
here. Uh, probably if you're offended by that comment, you're
probably not one of those people. I'll be honest. All right.
If you if you're offended by that comment, you're probably not
one of those people. This this moral effing will end well for
you. I'm just Dude, I'm not saying you're wrong. I'm I like covering
that content. It says a lot about me, okay?
But I'm just I'm telling you guys that it's just really difficult.
It's really difficult to make anybody care about the people in
the space. That that's just not going to happen. It's just not
going to happen.
So the the optics conversation, that's way easier. explaining
like the costbenefit analysis that should be involved in terms
of doing collaborations with Destiny, having him involve real
life political candidates. That's so much easier. >> Uh
earn Jesus was Buddha. True says, "Thanks for her philosophy."
You're welcome. It's like asking to define capitalism. Maybe
I don't know what you're talking about. Ashley says, "Treat treating
like friends that's recovering notification addiction enables
him to pretend like it's not a problem." I mean, that's probably
true, >> Oh, hold on. That Ashley comment was quite good.
One second. >> Ask an economist to define capitalism. Maybe.
I don't know what you're talking about. Ashley says, "You're
treating him like a friend that's in recovery and not actively
engaged in addiction enables him to pretend like it's not a problem."
I mean, that's probably true, but I need to convince Steven and
convince DG. Oh, well, truth be told, why? Hold on. I need to
convince this guy that I keep handing the keys to that this is
really bad. No, you just you're just waiting for him to actually
destroy himself. That's all you're doing, Connor. Unless you're
actively working on it, but I get the sense you're not actively
working on it. You're actively working on your channel and reacting
to Destiny as his as he implodes.
pulled uh at least according to him he has substantively reduced
his gooning and um hasn't engaged in this behavior since 2023
which I don't 2022 maybe um so I don't know if that's true or
not right so we kind of have to wait and see it's like finding
>> oh has he not engaged in any other self-destructive
behavior since 2022 or >> now that your friend has a [__]
heroin addiction and then they're like oh yeah like I only do
Molly now and then you're like that's still that's still bad.
Um, Sati says, "You guys are leaving out Jesus's brother in China."
That's kind of up. Yeah, Jesus's brother who got a like quarter
of a million people. Uh, Good Grief Griff says, "We'll get get
you eventually, Connor. I want you to come my way, not the other
one." Uh, Ryan Cougar says, "Connor, would you forgive Jeffrey
Epstein? What is your line?" Uh, no. Jeffrey Epstein should be
forgiven by God, not by me. Um, I would probably euthanize. I
would either incarcerate for life or euthanize Jeffrey Epstein.
Miles Well says, "Frankly, my criticism is that you could criticize
him more severely as a man-to-man way and still keep the bridge.
Steven isn't opposed to criticism as long as it's well founded.
I think you could." Well, I mean, this entire stream has been
effectively
a an analysis of the facts and a criticism. Miles Hot Wheels
says, "Totally get behind the idea of what you're doing. I just
think it'll do more do more harm than good as a friendly criticism
than you." Yeah, it absolutely could. Could 100% blow up in my
face. Uh, Grassroots says, "The most charitable I can feel about
Stephen is to think of him as an addict."
J, you're all so dumb. You fell for it, right? Destiny, Willie,
and Ethan are conspiring to prank Hassan at his community. This
is obviously just a theory, but hear me out. Ethan hopped on
a video call with Willie and Destiny to plan staging a fake internet
drama between them. They will tear themselves apart. Give us
on a little sense of a false sense of a W. Will Oh, sorry. I'm
not pulling this up on stream. Why is this Why is this like crossed
out? Uh, they'll tear themselves apart. Give us on a little sense
false sense of W. Willie faking the 911 call. I mean, okay, this
could be possible, right? This could be possible, but this cuts
out the entirety of the Rose thing. This would be totally to
take seriously. Like, this would just be embarrassing for you,
right? completely embarrassing for you. If this was all a fake
thing between Willie, Destiny, and Ethan, this would be embarrassing
for all of them. This would actually destroy all of them. This
is like a totally thing, which
I I guess it's Kathy who linked it. So, they'll tear themselves
apart. Give Hassan a little false sense of a W. Willy faking
the 911 call. Ethan calling out Destiny on stream. Desty switching
to Hassan's side, calling death to Israel, and defending terrorists.
Hassan doing his victory dance. Then, finally, when everything's
going well for Hassan, the next H3H3 video is content cop Hassan
with an intro. wake up Assan. This would be so I mean if Ethan
wants to tie himself to the guy who just was found to be like
credibly texting a 17-year-old
then I think that's a W for all of us probably. Maybe Willie
had a twin and his twin called the police. All right. All right,
dude. In active use. That's where I get the most sort of sympathetic.
Gotcha. Uh Dubie says, "Oh well, yeah, some political positions
are also moral ethical positions." Cass saying it makes sense
that Lbox supporting what Hassan believes is a genocidal supremacist
ethnostate is bad enough that he'd want to cut ties.
Um, yeah. Uh, I'd cut ties with a friend if sin somewhere in
reality. That's um or snakes and ladders for some of you. Sure.
Key code says depends on the DG. I'm spiritual so I can play
sin somewhere in reality. That's good. Um, Destiny is a moral
relativist. I'm sure morality is of
not to be aired. I'm really considering leaving you, dude. I
need reassurances and I don't think I'm the only one. Um about
it where some not be aired. Uh do what you got to do, bro. Like
if that this is like a four or five stream
going over
>> Well, I think the issue is Connor doesn't have the facts
at all, right? Connor should probably talk to somebody adversarial.
I would assume he should talk to somebody adversarial. But >> really,
so I mean, if you see it and you can't be a part of it, that's
fine. It happens. It happens. Bro doesn't even invest. Literally
just hordes. True. He didn't agree with him is the problem. True.
Bosch can go [__] himself. I largely agree. I think
objective morality exists, but it's very tribal. I think it's
based in nature. Vos is a narcoynicist that isn't well read enough
to know what a narcoinist is. True. Mad money maxes. I think
it's code to say that Jesse didn't have some idea that she wasn't
18. The messages he does have are smoke screen for possible deniability.
I think you're inferring malice that we don't have. Uh, can we
get under 18%. Um, sure. Objective morality would have to exist
for humans to make any kind of moral progress, but we say objective
morality is discoverable and we might not be there yet. Sure.
He's not only banning trans people from the military, he's stripping
them of their pensions. It's despicable. I think you're like
a few hours away uh ago. Objective morality is just a social
contract we all mostly agree on. Sure. Rationality is joined
to the hip with reason. So, how do you get to antithetical? Um,
I'm not sure if I have time to answer this question. I'm not
sure I understand it quickly uh fully. Are emotions necessary
at ends with uh rationality? No, but you should ultimately realize
that you're a partially rational, partially irrational emotional
creature. Destiny is literally effing over everyone. Well, I
mean, I would say that this is obviously uh it makes that job
of transferring 1 to 10% of the Twitch politics energy into the
real world. It makes it substantively more difficult. Jeffrey
Engel says, "It's peacemaker mentality. I'm fighting for peace
no matter how many men, women, or children I need to kill to
get it beast. I love peacemaker. What about the whole ex Dan
the diddler? Maybe. Uh, yes, absolutely. You can't be rational
and be ruled by your emotions. Sure. Like starving sucks and
we want to eat food, but it's also rational to eat food when
you're starving. Sure. Web tune says, "Uh, before the react segment,
what are your thoughts on Nick Funes going all in on Gavin Newsome
because he's Aryan?" Uh, I think
uh Ch
>> I think uh I think we're not getting anything else here.
I think >> then why would he start? I think he actually
has a Old Testament view of morality. Dubie says, "The forgiveness
graph works. If he accepts a sin and seeks atonement, he's you
see Mine Hunter. When you get bored of this brain rot, watch
Minehunter, please." I've seen the first season of Mine Hunter.
It's not bad. Okay, hold on. We need to take a look here. What
do we got after this? Oh my god, there's still a stale food shop.
There's the ABBA and Preach. I have not looked at anything else
today. It was Shawn and then it was uh Connor reacts. I I think
Connor is basically done, right? I don't think there's anything
else here.